Was ist mit meinem Controller los, warum geht mein Controller nicht?
Jetzt geht er, hä? Verstehen, oder?
Ja, Beta geht noch nicht los. Zumindest eben wo ich geguckt habe, ging es noch nicht los.
Na ja, halbe Stunde, 24 Minuten mit Maus und Tastatur, ja?
Ging in der Alpha auch, ich hoffe das geht wieder.
Du kannst jetzt ja im neuen Modern Warfare mit Maus und Tastatur eine Konsole spielen.
Du wirst dann halt dann auch mit anderen Maus und Tastatur-Spieler zusammengewürfelt,
beziehungsweise nicht mit Controller-Suits.
Allerdings muss ich euch ehrlich sagen, in der Alpha war Maus und Tastatur auch nicht das
Allheilmittel. Die Maus-Abtast-Rate hat sich angefühlt wie, keine Ahnung, wie, mir fällt
nicht mal was Vergleichbares ein. Wie ein Überlastet der Pentium 1 oder so.
Es war so, die Maus-Abtast-Rate war gefühlt irgendwie so. Also es hat es auch nicht wirklich
rausgerissen, ich hoffe das ist besser jetzt. Übrigens, wisst ihr was ich eben probiert habe?
Ich habe gedacht, ich mache jetzt ein super, nice Aufnahmesetup. Oh, ich muss, ich muss,
erinnert mich mal dran, wenn es losgeht Leute, wenn es losgeht, muss ich den Sound einschalten
hier. Da muss ich den Sound, kann den Sound jetzt schon mal kurz einschalten. Sound für
die PS4. Muss ich einschalten. Und ich muss, muss mich verzögern. Ich muss, ich muss
mich verzögern, weil wenn ich mich nicht eine halbe Minute, eine halbe Sekunde verzöger,
dann müsst ihr mich unbedingt dran erinnern Leute. Wenn ich das vergesse, dann passt mein
In-Game-Sound nicht zu meinem Gelaber. Hatten wir das letzte Mal auch schon. Es liegt daran,
dass meine Capture-Card nicht die neueste, also nicht, ich habe ja noch die HD, HD, wie
heißt das? HD 60 oder so. Und das Problem damit ist halt, die hat ein bisschen Delay,
aber ich sehe es nicht ein mit der Neue zu kaufen, weil ich spiele so wenig Konsole noch,
nehme so wenig von der Konsole auf. Beziehungsweise beim Aufnehmen ist ja kein Problem. Ich streame
so wenig live von der Konsole. Das ist jetzt ja auch nur Ausnahmen, weil es auf dem PC
noch nicht läuft. Wir probieren jetzt übrigens noch mal was aus, Leute. Wir probieren jetzt
noch mal was aus. Wir haben ja noch kurz Zeit. Ich habe übrigens gerade versucht, ich wollte
ein super nicees Aufnahmesetup machen. Ich habe versucht die Ports weiter zu leiten für
die PS4. Hat auch funktioniert. Also ich denke mal, das wird klappen. Allerdings was nicht
funktioniert hat, ich habe das hier probiert. Remote Play. Weil ich dachte mir, ich bin
mal super big brain, next level, 5 head. Oh, oh, ich habe mein Meme-Tool nicht an. Das
ist natürlich mit fast nichts irgendwie zu entschuldigen. Zumindest das funktioniert
nicht. Ich habe es versucht zu pairen und es funktioniert ums Verrecken nicht mit Remote
Play. Ich wollte nicht Remote Play, ich wollte an der PS4, aber ich wollte die Ausgabe streamen.
Aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Und wisst ihr, was man machen muss, dass man sich überhaupt
anmelden kann in Remote Play? Soll ich euch mal zeigen, was man machen muss, dass man sich
überhaupt anmelden kann in Remote Play? Dass man mal wieder sieht, was Sony für eine krütze,
dreckige Kacke verkauft an Software. Das muss man echt so sagen, da könnte ich mich aufregen.
Ich zeige euch mal, was man machen musste, um sich anzumelden. Sony baut richtig gute
Hardware. Aber die Software ist so übertriebene Scheiße, man weiß nicht, was mit denen los
ist. So, du musst einen Controller verbinden. Ich mach das jetzt mal kurz. Ich verbinde
jetzt mal, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal. Ich verbinde jetzt mal meinen Controller. So,
passt mal auf. Übelster Crap. Ja, können ja eh nicht spielen, weil die Beta erst in
5 Minuten on ist. Controller verbunden. Options. Ach fuck, ich bin schon eingeloggt. Ha, deswegen
funktioniert das nicht. Ok, zumindest, wenn man sich das erste Mal mit Remote Play verbindet,
muss man sich einloggen. Und dass man sich einloggen kann, muss man, jetzt passt auf,
muss man, das ist jetzt kein Witz, das habe ich im Sony Forum gefunden, muss man den Internet
Explorer aufmachen. Es ist kein Witz, ja. Jetzt darfst du nicht cheaten, das wird offiziell
supportet. Brauchst eine Tastatur. So, man muss mal den Internet Explorer, es ist ohne
Scheiß Leute, den Internet Explorer aufmachen, Internetsoptionen anklicken. Also merkt euch,
falls ihr euch nicht mit Remote Play verbinden könnt, Advanced drücken und dann hier runter
gehen auf Security und rausnehmen Server Zertifikatschecks. Die haben es nicht geschafft, ein gültiges
Zertifikat für ihre Drecks Remote Play kacke zu haben. Ich muss den Zertifikatcheck aus
dem Internet Explorer rausnehmen, dass Remote Play geht. Was hat denn Sony da wieder programmiert?
Waren die auf Fiverr? Haben die auf Fiverr gesucht hier? Waren die Fiverr und haben gesagt,
C++ PS4 Coding. Und haben dann irgendwie den Typ genommen von 477. Hier, den haben sie
genommen, der ist zu teuer, der ist zu teuer für Sony. Ja, Maximum Budget 5 Euro. Fuck,
gibt's nicht. Okay, es ist Windows, es reicht dort nicht. 5 Euro. 1 Euro bis 6 Euro. Die
hat Sony beauftragt hier, die Dudes. 5 Euro, 5477 Fiverr programmieren, ihren Remote Play
kacke zu programmieren. Ich hab's hier. Hier. Da hab ich sogar noch gefunden. Das musstest
du machen. Und meinst du, Sony hat das offiziell mal irgendwo hingeschrieben? Ne. Und C Crap
Remote Play Software funktioniert nur, wenn man Zertifikatschecks deaktiviert. Was haben
die sich gedacht? Das ist mit Sony nicht ganz richtig im Kopf. Vor allem, warum kann ich
meine Playstation, es geht ja noch nicht mal, ne? Das ist ja der Witz. Es geht ja noch nicht
mal. Ich konekte mich jetzt mit Remote Play und erfinde die Playstation nicht. Bei der
Xbox ist das easy as fuck, sich mit der Xbox zu verbinden. Da machst du die Xbox App auf.
Äh. Achso, ich hab meine Xbox nicht an. Ja gut, wenn ich meine Xbox an hätte, ähm,
dann würde das funktionieren. So. Reconnect your Controller, auch noch. Ok, ich reconnecte
mein Controller. Gut Sony, mach ich. Alles gut. So, ich hab mein Controller reconnected.
Mal gucken, ob die Beta geht. Hopp, Connection failed. Sehr gut. Perfekt. Hab ich eigentlich
die, hab ich das Game richtig eingestellt? Ich sehs, hab ich Modern Warfare eingestellt?
Ist das richtig, was ich da eingestellt hab? Auf Twitch? Ich sehs bei mir in der Vorschau
nicht. Ich glaub, ich hab, ich hab's richtig eingestellt, ne? Ask Freddy, Dankeschön.
Mit Prime. Pok. Eris. Hab ich richtig eingestellt, sehr gut. Seh ich das eigentlich in meiner
Vorschau nicht? Ich kann einfach hier gucken. Der Wubblowers. Der Wubblowers streamer Modern
Warfare. Ja, sehr gut. Perfekt. Huge Quali. Aber ernsthaft Leute, Zertifikatsdinger deaktivieren.
Ja, deswegen müssen wir jetzt noch was ausprobieren. Also mein ursprünglicher Plan war ja, dass
ich Remote Play anmache und dann einfach Remote Play hier im Fullscreen laufen lass. Ab Samstag,
ja. Remote Play hier im Fullscreen laufen lass und wir einfach ganz normal das im OBS
captchern, wie immer. Dass ich die ganze Capture Card raushaben, weil die Sache ist die, ähm,
ich will ja eigentlich mit der Capture Card gar nichts, gar nichts machen. Ich will einfach
nur das weiterleiten, ne? Warum Wubblowers? Weil das ein privater Account ursprünglich
war und eigentlich auch nicht so direkt gefunden werden wollte. Oder immer noch nicht will.
Nur von den Leuten, die es wirklich interessiert. Das ist einfach angenehmer. Ähm, wisst ihr
was wir jetzt mal probieren? Es kann sein, dass ich den Stream neu starten muss, weil
es abkackt. Ich blende, ich blende mal Elgato aus. Ich hoffe, das reicht. So, ich blende
die Elgato aus. Wir machen Game Capture HD auf. Big Brain Tool. Device is used by another
application. Sucked. Okay, was ist wenn ich das, was ist wenn ich das Capture Device lösche?
Remove. Man soll das ja closen alles, denke ich mal. Ah. Weil dann mach ich das nämlich
einfach in Fullscreen. 8 Fitch FPS, beste. Machen wir das in Fullscreen. One moment please.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert's, glaube ich. Oh. Sound muss ich schon ausmachen. Wobei, muss
ich den Sound ausmachen? Oh mein Leute, ich bin verwirrt. Fuck, wie kriege ich jetzt
den Sound gecaptured? Ich glaub, das funktioniert nicht so, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Hör ich denn den Sound selbst? Ich will den Sound selbst gar nicht hören. Weil die Sache
ist die, wenn ich coole Gameplays hab, würd ich die halt gerne capturen können und so
hab ich's halt nur im Stream, was bisschen wist ist. Ah, zum Glück hab ich den Stream
nicht angezeigt. Okay, es. Jaja, das bringt aber nichts, weil ihr wollt ja auch den Sound
hören. Ihr wollt ja auch den Sound hören. Das bringt mir ja nichts, wenn ich das so
mach. Ich hatte es eigentlich vor, ich mach das hier einfach auf Fullscreen und alles
ist gut. Aber bringt nichts. Weil dann habt ihr den Sound und ich den Sound und ich den
Sound verzögert. Das ist Müll. Das bringt nichts. Ja, dann beiß ich halt in den sauren
Apfel und wuss, wenn ich ein gutes Gameplay hab, dass ich das irgendwie ausm Stream nehm,
auch wenn's mich ein bisschen nervt. Mir fällt grad nichts anderes ein. Kinomodus hat das
Ding auch nicht. Ja, ich könnte mit VoiceMeter irgendwelche komischen Audio-Rooting-Geschichten
bauen, aber das mach ich jetzt nicht mal 10 Minuten, bevor die Beta startet. Naja, du
kannst, doch, doch, du kannst schon Ausgaben, die weißes wählen. Da müsste ich, da müsste
ich, lass mal überlegen. Da müsste ich als, das probieren wir mal aus. Ich hab ne Idee.
Ich nehm als Ausgabedevice, nehm ich die Soundkarte, die ich nicht verwende und die fügen wir
mal hinzu in OBS und gucken, ob dann, gucken dann, ob was passiert. Jetzt ist Big-Brain-Time
angesagt, ich sag's euch. Big-Brain. Wo stellt man das bei der Elgato um, das Ausgabedevice?
Hier, Settings, Audio, ne. Audio-Input. Weiß das jemand? Geht das überhaupt bei der Elgato,
dass man das Ausgabedevice umstellt? So. Glaube immer Standard-Audio-Gerät.
Standard-Audio-Gerät zackt aber mal richtig, ne.
Weil die Musik, mit der Musik los. Das bringt mir nichts, wenn ich das Standard-Ausgabegerät
umstelle. Weil wir können mal probieren, was passiert. Wir testen das jetzt mal. Ok, Sound-Settings,
Sound-Pen, das ist ja Windows-Logik, da muss man dann da hin immer. So und dann sagen wir
als Ausgabedevice. Genau und das da oder so, das verwende ich hier nicht. So, jetzt höre
ich keine Musik mehr. Ihr hört auch keine Musik mehr. Das ist aber denn schlimm, ich
höre In-Game-Sound. So, dann stellen wir das hier nämlich um. Weil mir geht es einfach
darum, dass ich nicht doppelt höre. Ich höre dann auch keine Follower-Sounds oder sonst
was. So und dann stellen wir das hier um und zwar auf speaker. Oh, ein bisschen lauter.
Jetzt habt ihr Sound und ich höre den nicht. Das ist ziemlich gut. So, dann stöpsel ich
jetzt an die Playstation, nämlich mein optischem Kabel, meinen Mixer dran und ruhte mir das
einfach auf den Kopfhörer und gut ist. Dann habe ich Sound. Ihr solltet jetzt auch, wir
probieren das jetzt mal aus. Ich mache jetzt mal eine Game-Capture auf. So, habt ihr Modern
Warfare Sound? Ja, ihr habt Modern Warfare Sound. Es ist übelst laut. Ok, es ist Modern
Warfare Sound. Viel zu laut, oder? Ich will überhaupt kein Mikro aufnehmen, Leute. Ich
will überhaupt kein Mikro aufnehmen. Wie kann ich denn den Crap ausmachen? Audio? Wie
kann ich dem sagen... Ah, der checkt das gar nicht, ne? Ach gut. Ja, ich habe jetzt
kein Sound, ne? Wo war ich denn hier? Naja, der nimmt mich hier nicht auf. Dann ist auch
gut. So, Hauptsache der... Ach, wisst ihr was? Wir machen das einfach hier auf. Aus. Ja,
hier. Bam. Die Elgato-Logik erschließt sich mir nicht so hundertprozentig, ehrlich gesagt,
aber ich glaube, jetzt ist es aus. Gut, gucken wir mal, ob die Beta schon losgeht. Hat das
jetzt gekriegt? Connection failed. Moment, geht überhaupt die Aufnahme noch? Ich glaube,
es kommt noch Speicher. Ah, ja. Ok, wir gucken jetzt mal. Also ihr hört was, ne? So. Ok,
wir gucken jetzt mal, was mit meiner Playstation los ist, weil irgendwie reagiert hier nicht
auf Inputs als Gefudel da. Leute. Leute, ich glaube, meine Playstation ist abgekackt. Lulwe?
Wo, blul? Die macht nichts mehr. Connection hat so sehr gefailed, dass jetzt vorbei ist.
Geh mal aus. Mal aus, Playstation. Ach, das geht, oder was? Aber Input mit dem Controller
geht nicht. Ja, das ist ja logisch, ne? Ist ja logisch. Was weiß ich auch sonst, ne? So,
ich muss jetzt noch mein Audio-Mixer-Geschiss anschließen an die Playstation. An die Spielstation
4. Wo hat das einen optischen Eingang? Da. So, und wenn ich Glück habe, sollte ich etwas
hören, wenn ich wieder einschalte und ihr auch. Ah, sie geht wieder an. Ich hab den
Controller, ja ja, aber ich hab den Controller angesehen, dass er verbunden ist mit der PS4.
Der hat ja noch geleuchtet. Also, ich hab den abgezogen und wieder angestöpselt. Was
ist Stream Extreme? Meine Lehrer wollen von mir, dass ich ein Programm erstelle, das
implizierte Typ-Konvertierung, explizierte Typ-Konvertierung mit der Klasse Convert-Konvertierung
mit den Methoden Pass verwende. Wir haben aber bisher nur Hello World in sich scharp gemacht
und gelernt, wie man ein Projekt richtig erstellt. Jetzt nur meine Frage, was wollen die von
mir? Ach, Typen-Casten ist eigentlich ein sinnvoller zweiter Schritt zum Lernen nach
Hello World. Ich mein, vielleicht sollte man den Leuten erstmal erklären, was Typen sind.
Hat gestartet? Oh, ach deswegen ist das Game abgekackt, weil die Beta gestartet ist. Jetzt
versteh ich's, haha. So Leute, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob der Sound passt, weil ihr
wisst, ich höre nichts. Ich höre auch keine Follows oder irgendwas. Ich höre nur Game
Sound. Ich hab übrigens auch keinen Sound gerade. Das ist glaube ich Absicht, dass
gerade kein Sound da ist. So, ich glaube, der Sound ist ein Ticken zu laut für euch,
oder? Ich mein, denkt dran, das ist Menümusik. Der Sound passt, ich glaube, der ist zu laut.
Wenn ich anfange zu ballern, hauen sie euch, hauen sie euch die Ohren weg. Ich mach mal
einen Ticken leiser. Glaubt mir, ich hab da mittlerweile schon ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Okay, so, Maustastatur anstöpseln an die PS4. Ich hoffe, das geht überhaupt. Wenn nicht,
muss ich da mein legales Cheating-Utensil rausholen für Maus und Tastatur, aber will
ich eigentlich nicht. Vielleicht die offizielle Maustastatur-Unterstützung verwenden. Maustastatur,
und Bro. Zack, dass die Maus an der PlayStation... Übrigens, war ein Tipp für alle, Tipp für
alle, die eine Corsair-Tastatur haben. Wenn ihr eine Corsair-Tastatur habt, ihr müsst
Lock-Taste und F1 gedrückt halten für irgendwie 10 Sekunden. Dann schaltet sich die Tastatur
in so einen treiberlosen Geschiss-Modus und ihr könnt sie verwenden auf der PS4. Guck,
jetzt kann ich es mit der Tastatur machen. Vorher nicht. Man beachtet diesen tollen
Account hier. Ah, Maustastatur angeschlossen. Huge, big brain. Warte, ich muss noch mal
schnell mal ein Headset entwirren, dann geht's los. Lipp, Headphone-User. Eieiei, was jetzt?
Alter. So. Wobblords at gmx.de. Übrigens, das ist auch die Adresse, an die alle Donations
gehen. Nur mal angemerkt. Ähm, so. Ähm, zack. Ok. Update. Gebaited. Hört ihr das? Hört
ihr den Gebaited Song? Weil ich höre nix. Habt ihr den Gebaited Song gehört? Ja, sehr
gut. Ja, Restart. Gut. Wie gesagt, ich höre nix. Also, falls ich Leute, falls ich heute
Follows übersehe, äh, nicht Follows, falls ich Subs und Gedöns übersetze, müsst ihr mir
unbedingt Bescheid sagen. Ich seh's zwar im Chat, aber ich hab kein akustisches Feedback
oder so. Ok, man kann das nicht überstehen. Ghostface Killer Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Das irritiert mich voll, dass man da keinen Sound hat. Press any key to start. Geht los.
Wo ist der any key? Das ist so ein Fußpedal. So, Multiplayer. Das war Options. Guck. Äh,
die Maus abtastrat ist, so wirklich flüssig ist das Ganze noch nicht, aber besser, auf
jeden Fall besser als in der Alpha. So viel kann ich sagen. Keyboard and Mouse. Ah, man
hat jetzt sogar ein Menü für Maus Sensitivity. Poggers, Alter. Poggers, sehr gut. Ähm, weil
ich hab nur zwei Presets, nämlich 800 DPI und 3000 DPI. 3000 DPI ist ein bisschen schnell,
also ich bin einmal über den Bildschirm mit 3000 DPI, so in, keine Ahnung, zweieinhalb
Zentimeter und mit 800 DPI brauch ich halt so das halbe Mousepad. Das heißt, das heißt
360 ungefähr das Mousepad so. Ähm, wow. Ich glaub das müssen wir, ich glaub das müssen
wir in-game einstellen. Mausrad geht nicht. Set. X. Ich glaub das müssen wir in-game
einstellen, ein bisschen gucken. Blablablablabla, Controller Mode, was? Maus Control Mode, Aim.
Gibt's da sonst noch? Legi-Legacy? Your Maus controls your Aim in all axis. Move is not
affected by the Maus. Your Maus controls your Aim in the hor- Was? Wer macht denn so was?
Maus smoothing. Aim. Nein. Ist das Auto, ist das Auto-Aim oder was? Ich weiß nicht was
das sein soll. Ähm, ok. Äh, ich brauch nochmal schnell hier die, ähm, EUs, ok, F, C, Crouch,
Crown, das übliche. Stance, Slide? Crouch, Slide? Ist das gleiche. Aufstehen mit C, Hilling
mit C. Äh, Left Shift ist Rennen. Äh, was ist Neifen? Was ist Messern? V? Nee. Sieht's
jemand? Wo steht's? Nee, hier. Ah. Mittlere Maus, das finde ich gut. Oder E, oder E. Diesel
Equipment, das, das werde ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen unbelegen. Egal. Open hier, open
nut, huge poggers. Ok, auf geht's. Wir werden die erste, die erste Runde ein bisschen einstellen
müssen. Kann ich euch gleich schon sagen. Also, Quick Play. Moment, nein. Weg. Ich will,
ich will, ich will auswählen. Filter. Hä? Hä? Wie, wie kann ich auswählen was ich
spielen will? Oh nee, Moment. Fuck. Ich muss, Options. Options. Audio. Headphones. Halt
die Klappe. Ok. So Leute, ich bin echt gespannt. Ich bin echt gespannt. Assault. Primary Weapon.
Ghost. Go, oh nee. Ghost, beste. Deltar, Deltar. Äh. Maus? Kastatur? Hallo? Bewegt
dich nicht. Was ist das denn? Hallo? Ich kann mich nicht bewegen. Was ist das denn?
Warum kann ich mich nicht bewegen? Kann ich, kann ich mich mit dem Controller bewegen?
Hä? Warum kann ich mich mit dem Maus, warum kann ich mich mit dem, Alter mein Controller
hat einen 1m USB Kabel dran. Damit, damit geht gar nichts. Wartet mal, das kann doch
nicht sein. Das muss man umschalten. Das muss man garantiert umschalten. Man muss Input.
Hier. Ist natürlich total beknackt, ja. Lass man das nochmal extra umschalten. Kickball.
Perfekt. Sehr gut. Sehr schön. Ok, Filter. Ach, jetzt kann man. Ok, Filtern. TDM, 20
Player, Team Deathmatch. Kommt, wir lassen einfach. Wir machen einfach Quickplay. Gutes.
Äh, Lautstärke war gut. Zu laut, zu leise. Wie gesagt, ich höre es jetzt ja nicht bei
euch in der Vorschau. Ich habe extra, extra Sound auf dem Headset, dass ich keine Verzögerung
habe. Ach, ich muss mich übrigens ver, ich, ich muss mich selbst, wir müssen, wir müssen
gleich mal was ausprobieren. Ich sag gleich mal, nächstes Game, sag ich, äh, so nach
dem Mono, Schuss, Schuss, Schuss. Und ihr müsst mir sagen, ob ich zu spät bin. Ich
bin wahrscheinlich zu spät. Ich muss mich wahrscheinlich noch verzögern. So ne, so
ne, keine Ahnung, 500 Millisekunden oder so. Und ihr müsst gucken, ob Sound und Bild
zueinander passt in Game. Was soll ich im Menü machen? Ach so, im Menü. Ach so, man,
das könnte, na. Können wir mal hier, ich, ich hau jetzt auf die Tastatur und ihr seht,
wanns umspringt. Ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen, der Sound von der Maus ist ein bisschen zu
spät. 3 Sekunden, nä. 2 Sekunden, ok. Aber der, aber der In-Game Sound war richtig,
ne. Halbe Sekunde, ich, ich, ich, ich mach mal gleich die Verzögerung rein. Mach mal
gleich jetzt hier, nachdem wir getestet haben, was In-Game alles funktioniert. Sensitivity
eingestellt haben, probieren wir das mal aus. Ghost. Oh, man stellt sich jetzt aus so nem,
alter ist das verschwommen. Boah, Alter, das ist die, die, die 360 Extreme Einstellung
mit der Maus gerade. Ohohoho, PDF, was ist das? Huge 360. Man, ok, man kann wenigstens
schonmal schon lang rennen. Oh, ey krass, die Maus ist viel zu schnell. Alter, ist die
Maus schnell? What the fuck? In the ass, shoot it. Ok, ich, ich schalte mal auf 800 DPI runter.
Ok, 800, 8. Es ist ganz, ok, es ist ein bisschen zu langsam, aber es geht eigentlich. Es ist
ein bisschen zu langsam. Kann man hier stelzen? Oh, Stelzer End hier. What the fuck, wo ist
hier was? Ey, jetzt ist die Maus zu langsam. Ah, typisches Call of Duty von hinten gebashed.
Ach ja, wir müssen, wir müssen noch die ganzen Mist ausschalten, schalten, schalten, warte
mal. Filmgrain weg. Wo ist Motionblur und Geschiss? Kann man den? Ja, Motionblur aus.
Textchat aus, da wird eh nur geflammt. Weapon Motionblur aus. Ja, wir können ruhig abfliegen,
das ist ok. Was, X? Oh nein, es ist Schild-Camp-Action. Ah! Musst du es mit dem Xim verbinden? Nö, warum
sollte ich das machen? Ok, wir müssen die Sense ein bisschen hochstellen, das ist sehr
wichtig. Ah, ok. Audio, ne nicht Audio, General. Ne, Keyboard, Maus. Ganz schön langsam. Äh,
kann das sein, dass das überhaupt keine Auswirkungen hat? Ach, das ist Menü. Menü, warum gibt es
dafür was eigenes? Äh. Ok, das schaut ein bisschen besser. Wie ist Lautstärke, passt?
Nice, ok, perfekt. So, ich stelle hier direkt nach der Runde. Jetzt haben wir ja alles soweit
in-game eingestellt, dann stelle ich gleich noch das Delay ein, dann passt alles. Alter,
ich blicke schon wieder unruh durch, wenn ich mal die Gegner rumstelze, ne. Ach so, für
Monos, Team Deathman. Enter. DDM, oder? Ok, hier wird rumgestelzt. What the fuck, aber.
Hat man irgendwie so ein Self-Heal? Tonunscharf, ja. Ich stelle die Verzögerung vom Ton gleich
ein, da müsste es halbwegs passen. Hat man eine Lebensanzeige? Ne, hat man nicht. Komm
back. Äh, wie sieht es mit Ping-Anzeige aus? Immer noch nicht? Na geil. Keine Kill-Anzeige.
Ey, nicht Kill-Anzeige, Ping-Anzeige, was laber ich da für Blödsinn? Nicht mal Ping-Ball,
ne, gar nichts. Was, das ist billig? War das nicht eigentlich so, war das nicht so, dass
man keine Mini-Nap hat? Schreckt. Moment, warum legt er, warum legt er, duet sich nicht
hin? Warum legt er sich nicht hin? Also C gedrückt halten, legt er nicht hin. Der kniet,
der kniet nur. Achso, Steuerung, ja ok. Aber ah, C ist light. Ne, ne, ne, ok, passt, kapiert.
Das ist ja richtig nice. Ok, nach der Runde stellen wir Audiokram ein. Jetzt mal checken,
wo hier irgendwas abgeht. Moment, F, R fürs werfen, Q ist? Hat der Stun jetzt gestunnt?
Ah, wir haben keine Mini-Map. Ne, verstehe. Das ist schon ein bisschen unfair mit Maus
ein wenig, ein wenig. Achtung, Achtung Leute, huge play, huge play. Was macht eigentlich
X? Ah, X ist das kommende Schild. Stecktor. Ach, UAV, welcher Knopf? Was, mount? Wow,
mount? Ok. Mount? Headklitschen, eingebauter Headklitsch, huge. Eingebauter Headklitsch.
Progas. Eats. Wir bleiben jetzt hier einfach sitzen, bis die um die Ecke kommen. Headklitsch
beste. Ok, ich glaube die kommen nicht um die Ecke. Oder die Ghoststelzen alle. Oh,
ein Predator. Was, was ein Predator? Auch drei? Eins? Alter, was, was ist der Killstreak?
Vier? Ah, da stehts. Oh, huge kills Leute. Wow, wow. Bam, in your face. In dein Gesicht
Alter, wie das Gears of War sagen würde. Erstmal, erstmal ne Runde Headklitschen. Erstmal
ne Runde Headklitschen. Oh, wir gewinnen. Ok, ich checke null, wo Gegner kommen. Aber
das macht ja nix. Einfach nicht bewegen. Easy, easy win. Erste Runde, easy win. Zehn,
drei. Progas. Ok, ich stell jetzt die Soundverzögerung um, weil das ist wahrscheinlich übelst
nervig zuzugucken. GG Eats. Ups, ist das mein Kill? War ich das? Ne. Einen Moment,
die Maus ist ja am falschen Rechner. Was ein Gefrickel hier. Ok. Ok, ich hab jetzt keine
Maus dran, keine Tastatur dran. Also ich verzögere mich mal um. Oh, ne oder Leute. Geht das
auch nochmal schneller? Ich hab ne Idee. Big brain, Leute. Huge play. Nice, oder? 500.
Ah, da reicht 500 IQ nicht für. Das ist eigentlich, eigentlich schon 900. Ja, ich maus, dass der
Durbel unterstützt. So, guck mal, ob das jetzt besser ist. Es ruckelt. Igitt. Guck mal,
ob das jetzt besser ist. Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf. Wir schießen jetzt. Bis jetzt? Also
ich müsste jetzt ein bisschen näher dran sein. Halbe Sekunde, immer noch halbe Sekunde, ok.
Ja, machen wir. Äh Leute, ihr erkennt euch da besser aus als ich. Kann man sich irgendwie
heilen? Da war doch grad ein Gegner, oder? Da war doch ein Gegner. Nee, das war mein Dude.
Kann man sich Spritze geben irgendwie? Ok, G ist. Was zum Teufel ist das? Ein Nate, oder?
Ok. Die sind bestimmt bei A, die Typen. Fuck. Aber den hat man gehört. Den hat man gut gehört.
Das ist schon mal schön. El Gato GUI ist offen? Warum das denn? Wartet mal. Warum ist das El
Gato GUI offen? Hä? Ja, wir haben er gleich. Wartet mal. Ich sehe es jetzt leider nur
mit übelstem Delay. So, ich mach die Maus jetzt mal hier weg. Das sollte jetzt eigentlich
gleich zugehen. Ist jetzt zu? Alter, was ist das denn für ein Crap jetzt? Jetzt muss
ich den Display wieder umschalten. So. Normalerweise geht das zu, wenn man die Maus weggenuft.
Was zum Teufel ist das denn jetzt schon wieder? Exit Fullscreen? Achso. Ich weiß, wie man
den Kram bedient. Ich weiß auch, dass man es nicht forcieren kann. Ok. Jetzt ist es
besser, ne? Ok. Ok, also der Maus-Input ist deutlich angenehmer als in der Alpha noch.
Ey, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumstelzen. Das sind die übelsten Stelzer
in der Welt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe
keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle
rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die
Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine
Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Typen
alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung wo die Typen alle rumsteln. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wusste ich doch, wusste ich doch
wow, von wo? alter von wo?
what the, what the fuck?
der, der Sound ist, der Sound ist da
der Sound schibetet übelst
hab sie das gehört?
alter das hat sich angehört, als ist der Typ 1,5 cm von mir weg vorbeigelaufen
Ghoststelzer am Start
Huge Ghoststelzer
Massive Ghoststelzer
Müsste ich ne UAV haben lassen?
UAV?
Ok, map layout, kapiert Schnull bis jetzt
Schnull bis jetzt?
Konnte man sich nicht ranstelzen?
UAV, sehr schön
Oh, andere Richtung
Oh, bis jetzt ist nur eins ganz nice
Fuck, Muni all
Spielt sich, also, naja, also es spielt sich besser als, als ich mit nem Controller je könnte
Na, sowas willst du nem Controller im Leben ertreffen
Das Problem ist nur, dass der Input ziemlich, ziemlich lahm ist
Und nur ein bisschen schneller rennen könnte
Also, die Abtastrate der Maus ist wirklich nicht hoch, das merkt man sofort
Also vor allem wenn man in die 104 FPS PC und alles Zeugs Master Race gewöhnt ist
Oh, was war das? Alter, was?
Wo kam der denn bitte schön her jetzt?
Einer hat schon eine Nuke, gibt er Leute die spielen übelst gut?
Also das juckt mich jetzt nicht so, ob ich jetzt ne Nuke direkt hab oder na fuck da oben war ein Gegner, ich hab ihn gesehen
So, wir sliden jetzt, übelst huge slide
Jetzt machen wir hier so nen Camper bring hin
Und jetzt wird er weggestellt da oben
Können die jetzt von hinten auch hier kommen? Nee, oder? Doch, haha
Der Sound ist der übelste Chebat, ich sag's euch Leute
What?
Der Sound ist Chebat des Todes ey, habt ihr das auch?
Das ist übelst Chebat der Sound
Du denkst sonst wo hier Gegner stellst und dann ist dann gar nix oder ganz woanders
Ist das nicht tot?
Tactical ey, ich hab keine ammo mehr, fu
Wo ist er? Keiner mehr da, kommen die jetzt von hier?
What? Okay
Maxi Klasse, das ist die Standard Klasse, ich hab noch gar nix
Nee, Kopfhörer hab ich nicht falsch auf, Blödsinn
Okay, Maus ist n ticken schnell noch, wieder jetzt, n ticken zu schnell
Ach, der lebt nicht
Ich höre hinter mir was, ist aber nix
Wie hältst du das?
Achtung, fuck, von hinten
Okay, 15, 11, geht gut, play
Aber ey, fühlt sich nicht schlecht an, wie ist das ohne Minimap nicht wild?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich war nie der Krisenfan, ich meine, ich finde, dass der Blackbird der bester Killstreak ever war
Aber an sich war ich nie so ein großer Fan, diesem Minimap nachgerenne von Cod
Hast du mal mit dem Xym probiert? Nee, noch nicht
Okay, create a class, geht das irgendwo? Weapons, Killstreaks
Okay, also Weapons, was kann man machen?
Killstreak select
Was gibt's denn überhaupt alles?
Personal Raider, Escort, Analyzer
Ah, ULV, was interessiert mich, meine Ali's, die unlockt man?
Oh, hab ich jetzt unlocked? Nee
Ach, ah, unlocked at level, okay, also ULV
Also ULV
Äh, okay, ach, ich war schon in der Matchmaking drin, okay
Als nächstes müssen wir uns eine eigene Klasse machen
It's a sniper, Demolition, Heavy Support, Assault, Ghost
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, die Grossklasse gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut
Schönes rumgestellte
Das Movement ist auf jeden Fall mal ganz nice
Okay, wir stellten hier durch
Oh, da brennt einer
Jetzt wird von der Seite reingestellt
Wow, the fuck, Alter, was ist das?
Okay, Alter, hinter, wie immer, ganze Kottkacke immer von hinten weggebasht
Smearplayout ist erst mal übelst verwirrend, Alter, was ist da los?
Es ruckelt übrigens, ich glaub, da hinten war ein Gegner, oder?
Voll um die Ecke, WTF
Nee, doch
Jetzt fände ich es echt nice, eine Ping-Anzeige zu haben
Okay, jetzt fang ich an, das ist echt cool
Nee, man braucht keinen Playstation Plus
Na, wo kommen die alle her?
Alter, was ist das?
Das ist immer die ganze Zeit immer...
Das ist ja hinter mir gespotet, oder was?
Haben wir hier drüber?
Okay
Alter, was ist das?
Haben wir den hier drüber?
Da oben ist ein Dude
Ich versuche replica zu sächen
Wir haben Alpha getötet.
Gegner, UAV, vorwärts!
Wir sind unbravo, steig zu!
Wir haben Charlie verloren!
Wir sind unbravo!
Gegner, UAV, vorwärts!
Wir haben Kontrolle!
Wir haben zwei Objekte.
Nimm die 3.
Sie haben eine Kruise missalert.
Gegner, UAV, vorwärts!
Wir haben Alpha getötet.
Gegner, Alpha getötet.
Wir haben 12 getötet.
Gegner, UAV, vorwärts!
Das ist gar kein Gegner.
Das ist einfach nur Pixelbrei.
Da ist ein Gegner am Start.
Ja, okay.
Map ist wir, aber ich glaube so schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Man muss ja auch die geilen Skuff Jump Moves machen.
Richtig.
Es ist ein bisschen problematisch, dass wirklich von jeder Seite
alles kommen kann.
Was geht hier?
Hinter mir ist was verreckt.
Der Sound ist so mega chibay.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Alles ist übelst voll mit Gegnern.
Und wenn du dann ein Sieß hörst, hast du nicht gehört.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Du hast laufen Gegner.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Okay, vielleicht muss man einfach drauf scheißen, was man hört.
Hinter mir.
Den haben wir jetzt gut gehört.
Da ist noch mehr.
Jetzt habe ich auch wieder was hinter mir gehört und es war nichts da.
Komisch.
Gehen wir da schön von hinten gestellt.
Lol.
Alter, schön.
Danke für die Kamera, Shake.
Wo ist die Minimap?
Die ist jetzt da.
Können die da oben rein?
Fuck.
Was ist das?
Alter.
Was?
Es hat doch direkt neben mir geschossen gerade.
Ihr habt es doch auch gehört, oder?
Direkt neben mir ist jemand gelaufen.
What the fuck?
Da hinten sind noch mehr.
Hat das jetzt gerade auf mich geschneibert?
Weiß man nicht.
Ah, das ist meiner.
Lol.
Die Map ist ganz schön groß.
Die Map ist ganz schön groß, Leute.
Easy win.
Das sind nicht die eigenen Leute.
Da war noch eben gar keiner.
Also der Sound ist wirklich hyper.
Jebait.
Ups, ich habe die Maus gewackelt.
Jetzt ist die Elgato wieder angegangen.
Oh ne, Elgato.
Please wieder ausgehen.
Wieder ausgehen, Elgato.
Komm schon, geh aus.
Ja, sehr gut.
Jetzt ist wieder eingegangen.
Sehr nice, Elgato.
Elgato, kannst du auch wieder ausgehen?
Nice.
Elgato, please ausgehen.
Okay, anscheinend nicht.
Gott, ist das ein Kreuz.
Alles nur, weil ich gedacht habe, ich kann ein paar Gameplays aufnehmen.
Nebenbei.
Okay, jetzt sollte das Elgato-Ding wieder ausgehen.
Okay.
Okay, wir nehmen wieder den Ghost-Stell-Sound.
Danach machen wir uns eine eigene Klasse.
Das Elgato-Ding sollte gleich wieder sich ausblenden.
Okay.
Ah, das ist die Etaille schon mehr.
Securing C.
We've got Charlie.
Reloading.
Guck, jetzt habe ich noch etwas hinter mir gehört, da ist nichts da.
Wir sind doch nicht die eigenen.
Für mich sehen die Gegner plötzlich gleich aus, alle.
Reloading.
Assist your team at Charlie.
Securing B.
Allied UAV overhead.
Bravo, secure.
We've lost Charlie.
Reloading.
We're on Alpha, stand by.
Alpha secure.
Assist your team at B.
Allied cruise missile launched.
Fuck, ich wollte beide wegsprayen.
Ich bescheuere mich, den ersten wegsprayen, sondern den zweiten.
Warum du dieses Jahr so gehypt bist?
Ich würde es nicht gehypt nennen, ich bin das erste Mal,
so dass ich nicht gleich keinen Bock habe.
So dass ich nicht gleich keinen Bock habe.
Alter, ich denke auf das Gegner.
Dann secure mal B.
Bravo, secure.
Reloading stun.
Allied chopper gunner arriving now.
We have two objectives.
Wow, geile Supportkiste.
We've lost Bravo.
We have two objectives.
Enemy at Alpha, go!
Ja, du kannst ja null bewegen, wenn du geflasht bist.
Hä?
Was denn hier eben noch drin?
Moment.
Alter.
Potato Ass.
Ach gut, du kannst nix machen.
Hätte halt gerne Ping anzeigen.
Meiner Sack doch so.
Wo kam der dude her?
Kann man hier durch?
Aha.
Oh ne.
Die sollen wir woanders cruisen.
Oben ist was drinne.
What?
Ich hab die überhaupt nicht gesehen am Fenster.
Das ist nicht drei, aber es ist drei oder es ist 6 gegen 6 oder so.
Das ist geschreckt.
Wir müssen das TDM-Scan spielen.
Und danach müssen wir ne Klasse machen, Leute.
Auch.
Ich genieß die Waffe Sack auf Range, Mega.
Ich hab gerade was gehört.
Ich weiß nicht wohin.
Das Spiel läuft.
Ich würde sagen zwischen 60 und 30.
Also konstant 60.
Also es sind definitiv keine konstanten 60.
Da oben drin ist ein Dude.
Oh, das war ne, das war ne Claim oder sowas.
Kann man irgendwie reinstellen in das Haus?
Zu viel Dreckgeschotter.
Alter, was ein Pech.
Hier großartig rumrushen ist hier auf jeden Fall nix.
Die Runde dauert auch ewig.
Okay, man kriegt das angezeigt.
Was war das jetzt für ein krasser Park?
Und den Fluss hab ich noch überhaupt nicht raus.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo Gegner herkommen, geschweigen, wo irgendwas spawnen oder so.
Null.
Ich denke, ob es ist Eats, da werden sie gereckt.
Ne, da gehts gar nicht lang.
Es gibt keine MSS mit der Maus.
Es hört sich wirklich an, als ist direkt irgendein Dude hier gerade an mir vorbeigelaufen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
What the fuck?
MSS mit Maus? Ja, das wär richtig krass.
Ach so, nicht Kollege.
Oh, da sind noch mehr.
Er brennt.
Hier ist noch einer drin.
Alles draufschießen kann ich nicht.
Aber erstmal, erstmal den Flow der ganzen Geschichte irgendwie verinnerlichen.
Wie kommt man hier irgendwie drum herum?
Ob wir gewinnen?
Dude, von mir her.
Okay, so jetzt wollen wir noch ne Klasse machen.
Ne, ne, es gibt keine MSS für Kammern.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt ne Klasse machen.
Oder mal zumindest was anderes ausprobieren.
Und dann stellen wir mal im Filter einfach nur noch ein normales 20 Mann TDM ein.
1113.
Man merkt man direkt, wie viel besser einfach Tastatur und Maus ist.
Stell euch mal vor.
Ich würde das mit Controller spielen.
Okay, Weapons.
MP5.
Ach, das ist einfach hier Standard Zeug.
Aber MP5 wollte ich eh ausprobieren, das passt eigentlich.
So.
Hier kann man jetzt zig Sachen customisen.
Unlockt sich was mit Level...
Item unlock at Level 3.
Ich bin nur Level 5.
Oder ist das Waffenlevel?
Ah, das ist Waffenlevel, okay.
Aha.
Double time.
Okay, was haben wir für Perks?
Tactical Sprint.
Ah, das brauch ich nicht.
Hardline.
Okay, das ist nice.
Ich brauch unbedingt hier Ghost-Stellzahler.
Overkill, Carry Truth, Primary Weapons, Amped.
Double Duration, Techn...
Moment, nee.
Amped, Faster Weapon Swap.
Okay.
Heal Upgrades.
Was sind das denn?
Feel Upgrades?
Crack, Tactical Grenade.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Was haben wir...
Ach hier, Feel Upgrades.
Ach, das ist dieses Ding.
Das ist das Headclitch-Ding, das wir aufgestellt haben.
Munitionsbox.
Ah.
Okay, das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Killstreaks.
Personal Raider.
Ah.
Counter-UAV, UAV, Predator.
Ah ja.
Okay, was anderes haben wir noch nicht.
Unlocks at level 15.
Okay, wir müssen einfach leveln, so wie es aussieht.
Einfach leveln.
Filter.
Machen wir hier Domination.
Domination B.
Ah, okay, ich muss...
Ich muss alles spielen.
Oder?
Muss ich alles spielen?
Kann man so einen Controller vielleicht draus machen?
Nee, man muss alles spielen.
Okay, keine Chance.
Quickplay.
Ja, ja, PC.
Wenn du auf dem PC spielst, dann kriegst du auch Aim Assists.
Dann kriegst du auch Aim Assists.
Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass Crossplay ein bisschen ein Reinfall wird, weil auf dem PC wahrscheinlich die ganzen Hexortoots am Start sind nach irgendwie zwei Wochen.
Und eigentlich jeder Playstation-Spieler einfach Crossplay ausschalten wird, dass sie untereinander mit Controller spielen.
Fertig.
Also wahrscheinlich wird von Crossplay gar nicht so viel übrig bleiben, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Okay, was haben wir denn zu bieten hier?
Assault haben wir noch nicht gespielt.
Irgendwann Assault.
Ach so, bin ich eigentlich immer noch verzögert.
Dann muss ich glaube ich noch eine halbe Sekunde länger einstellen, oder?
Oh, das ist hart mit dem Ding hier.
Wollt ihr mal interessieren, ob das One-Headed mit einem Dreier burst?
Alter, krasse Aim, Scheiße.
Das ist halt hart, wenn du null Aim Assists hast.
Und was halt auch ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, ich meine für mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr rauszulegen, aber die Bauch sich anders anfühlt.
Aber es ist schon merkwürdig.
Es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du mit 144 Herzen ordentlicher, ich weiß nicht was es ist, Abtastrate oder so spielst.
Richtig 100 Pro ist es nicht, aber immer noch für mich 100 Mal besser als Controller.
We change my loadout.
So, dass wir gewinnen.
Hä, der Dude war direkt nebenan mir.
Alter, wie lange hält das Ding?
Drei Stunden ey.
Das Ding hat ewig gehalten.
Wir müssen ordentlich stelsen.
Oh man, Chat war übrigens kaputt, ich hab nichts gesehen, falls jemand was geschrieben hat.
So eine Pingartzeige wäre echt schon was.
Alter geht mal aus dem Weg.
What?
Der ist nicht gespielt.
Warum lag das so bei dir?
Naja das ist die normale Playstation, nicht die Pro.
Die Maus ruckelt halt, weil Mausunterstützung irgendwie noch nicht so der Wahnsinn ist.
Alter, die halten ja ewig Distanz.
What?
Alter was?
Außerhalb der Mapper.
Ah, das bounce nicht das Teil, ok.
Oh, huge play.
What?
Ach, der Typ ist tot.
Was?
Ihr wollt die MP5 sehen?
Ok.
Aber die Klasse ist da.
Personal Radar Coverage.
Wir sprayen Pray.
MP5, die MP5 gefällt mir, die sieht schon mal gut aus.
PC Battle Net, ja.
Hallo?
Huge, huge speed.
Huge speed.
Alter, du wirst laufen von der Seite gebashed irgendwie, soll man das denn spielen gescheit?
Ok, wir machen jetzt den Ausruhmstelzer.
Hinter mir war was, ne?
Alter, das hört sich an, als ist wieder einer direkt durch mich durchgelaufen gerade.
Ah, wo genauer.
Ja.
Ok.
Ja, so ein Ding auch, das ist nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Das war langsam als normaler Sprint, ja.
Super Sprint, also hier, aktuell ist es gerade einfach Shift drücken.
Neun, dreizehn.
Ich sag euch, nächste Woche Dreierkarte Eats.
Ach ne, nächste Woche läuft's gar nicht mehr.
Ich brauch immer ein bisschen, bis ich mich an die Games gewöhnt hab.
So, Weapons, zeig ich mal.
Operators?
Das ist nur Optik, oder?
Grill?
Ne, das Grill schreit bestimmt.
So wie in Battlefield.
Oh, was ist mit dem los?
Ok, also wirklich auszurüsten, gibt's da nichts?
Restock?
Was haben wir denn wirklich, was?
Wir spielen jetzt ein bisschen MP5.
Wir spielen jetzt ein bisschen MP5 und probieren einfach mal aus, was man da an Attachments drauf machen kann.
Das sind jenische Spezialeiten, du meinst wegen den Gardinen.
Oh, wir stellzen wieder vom Auto runter.
Ok, wo rennt man hier am besten lang?
Ok, wir Captchern erstmal, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
So, kann man jetzt hier wieder hoch?
Ich glaub, das ist besser, als wenn man den Mainweg rennt.
Alter, da steht er in der Ecke, ich fass es nicht.
Ich hab ihn sogar gehört, ich dachte, ne, das ist bestimmt wieder durch die Wand.
Aber war es nicht, war nicht durch die Wand.
Geht nix.
Hier drinnen müsste der MP5 eigentlich gut sein, aber die Distanzen sind tatsächlich relativ weit.
Oh, MP5 über Range.
Und gefickt.
Hört man die Gegner gut, man hört die Gegner zu gut. Man denkt, lauft man einem Gegner vor sich, obwohl er überhaupt nicht vor einem ist.
Und wenn man einen vor sich hat, hört man ihn manchmal nicht. Also Sound ist merkwürdig, ich hab schon auf Headphones gestellt.
Hier lang ist ziemlich beknackt.
Die Rush auch zu viel, muss einfach warten, bis sie herkommen.
Okay, aus der Hüfte über die Range geht nicht.
Häh?
Ich hab's wieder angedeutet, da war einer rechts.
Den haben wir gut gemacht.
Oh, das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Es war übrigens direkt wieder vor mir einer, zu hören.
Habt ihr das?
He takes those points. Machen wir.
He retakes so was von.
What? Ist der da gerade gespawnt?
Wow, huge slide.
Ja, ist klar, das hat er überlebt.
Ist das ein Kopf oder so mit der MP5?
Alter, wenn ich mich aus der Range mit der MP5 killen kann, dann sackt das Ding einfach.
Oh nee, keine Shotgun, please.
Nee, time to kill ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Time to kill ist ganz okay.
Der Carlson, dankeschön.
Laut Sound ist hier einer gestorben gerade.
Drei Stunden.
Ich bin immer von der Seite.
Alter, was halten die denn aus? Soll ich da noch alles drauf schießen?
Okay, wo kommt der Dude her? Hier oben, raus?
Da sitzt er.
Okay, Achtung Leute, mit was nehme ich den Schneiber? Fuck, Alter, ich will nicht Schneiber, ich will den Typ wegschneibern.
Nein, keiner da. Komm, Schneiber. Auf, Schneiber. Warum kommt da jetzt keiner? Ich will jetzt Schneiber.
Okay, fertig, Schneiber. Ich höre was hinter mir. Alter, das war jetzt ein Teammate.
Da können wir nicht durch in der Mitte, wir müssen jetzt drum herumstelzen. Fuck, Mann, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo es hier drum herumstelzen geht auf der Map.
Da lang.
Ja, ist klar. Kommt da angeschleidert. Schreckt einen übrigens weg.
Oh, guck mal, ich habe ein Ding hier.
War der im Haus, oder war das einfach der Nebe? Kann man durchfelsen?
Ja, und den Sound müssen wir übrigens gleich ausstellen, weil es übelst nervig wird.
Von wo, von wo? Hä? Was war das? Hat er schon den Flick, den Lock-on-Bot oder was?
Das geht ja wenigstens.
Also eins fehlt mir in dem Game, was für mich ein Grund ist, das nie auf der Konsole wieder anzufassen, keine Ping-Anzeige.
Und sollten die wirklich auf die glorreiche Idee kommen und auf dem PC keine Ping-Anzeige einbauen, dann wird das einfach nicht gekauft.
Egal was es ist, wir sind im Jahr 2019. Ich will zumindest halbwegs erkennen können, ob ich jetzt um die Ecke gekillt wurde, weil es eine Waffe ist, die ich um die Ecke killen kann oder ob ich um die Ecke gekillt wurde, weil ich 150 Pinger habe.
Ich meine, wenn ich das schon sehe, hier teilweise Matches mit 120 oder so. 120, ey. Wenn es auf dem PC keine Ping-Anzeige, ich sag's euch hier und jetzt, ohne Scheiß, wenn es auf dem PC keine Ping-Anzeige gibt, kaufe ich das Game nicht.
So sieht's aus.
Ist so. Wie spielt es sich? Ja, eigentlich, auch wenn die Leute Bedenken haben, typisch COD Random.
Ping-Anzeige gibt es im Game in den Netzwerkoptionen. Wo sind der Netzwerkoptionen?
Im Full Release. Im Full Release. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man sowas einbauen könnte, ne?
Wir haben wieder die Crap MP5 genommen. Aber wir spielen auch ein bisschen an die MP5, auch wenn sie Crap ist.
Wir securen sowas von Bravo.
Übel freudig, ey. Du machst nichts mit dem Ding. Hoffentlich können wir kleine eigene Klasse machen, eine ordentliche.
Danke für das Wackeln der Kamera. Sehr gut. Ich guck dir mal den Sprint an. Was geht mit dem jetzt ab?
Alter, das fuckt mich an dem Code jetzt schon ab. Dass du laufend irgendwo von unsichtbaren Gegnern gekillt wirst. Vielleicht liegt das einfach nur an der Auflösung meiner sackigen alten PS3.
So, wir sprinten jetzt mal drüber. Ob da was geht, ey. Ja, ist klar. Ich hab zwei Schüsse bei ihm abgegeben. Zwei halbes Magazin.
Der Minimap gibt es nur, wenn ULV oder Personal ULV am Start ist.
Ich will hier eigentlich nicht drinnen liegen bleiben.
Ich bin übrigens im Arsch. Was war denn das für ein Soundgrader?
Ach nee, fuck. Okay, huge flanking nicht. Huge flanking ist. Okay, es ist, killt mich alles schneller. Der Multiplayer spielt sich typisch code chaotisch, also nichts. Nee, alles verwalten.
Wow.
Ist weg.
Oh mein Recht, übelst langsam.
Okay, warum explodiert das?
Ich glaube, der explodiert das.
Old. Ja, richtig old. Krasse stats, ey. Hyper stats.
Die sind nicht sterben.
Achtung.
Die siehst du da hinten doch im Leben nicht.
Eine Claymore.
Die Maps, also die ist ziemlich groß. Vor allem von außerhalb ist die ziemlich groß.
Und du hast halt absolut keine Ahnung, wo irgendwelche Gegner sind.
Es lohnt sich jetzt auch null da hin zu rennen. Oh, da kommt was.
Wie schnell war der bitte tot?
Die sterben teilweise übel schnell und manchmal gar nicht.
Ja, merkwürdig.
Spielt das von euch jemand auf der PS Pro? Ist das auch so schwammig?
What the fuck, Alter.
Geiler Schneibern.
Ich wollte jetzt mal einen Schneibern wenigstens.
Gibt keinen Schneiber.
Das schnelle Sterben, es ist merkwürdig. Es ist wirklich merkwürdig.
Manchmal, ihr habt ja gesehen, manchmal schießt du drauf wie sonst.
Übrigens, warum heiße ich eigentlich Kicks Reno wie mein Battle-Net-Name?
Warum heiße ich nicht Coggers Poggers wie ich auf der PlayStation heiße?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Man unlockt das dann Cluster Strike?
Wie unlockt man das?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das unlockt.
Meine Level habe ich doch offensichtlich auch nicht schon wieder diese Kack-Map.
Okay, vielleicht können wir einfach ein bisschen zu lernen.
Und wir wissen, dass die MP5 in der Ursprungsfassung sackt.
Also spielen wir wieder komisches Ghosts.
Oder was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl? Demolition.
AK-47, Salt, Demolition.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Achtung!
All der Munition!
Wolltest du die Sounds? Nein, ich wollte die Sounds nicht deaktivieren.
Ganz ohne Sounds ist doch richtig bescheuert.
Nee, das ist einfach nur Krixelbrei, der kein Gegner ist.
Durch die Häuser ist Kacke.
Irgend sowas, wenn man muss außen lang stellen.
Das sieht richtig aus wie eine 2. Weltkriegskarte.
War auf die Ecke halt.
Andersherum.
Das Regen dauert zu lang.
Alter, wo ist der? Wir sind 50 Gegner.
Wo ist die Grußmisse?
Grußmisse, auf geht's!
Da, da heizen wir jetzt voll rein.
Bam, weg.
What? Ach, da oben.
Das ist eine Marketing-Beta, eindeutig.
Keine richtige Beta.
Weil es funktioniert jetzt mal einiges noch nicht und man hat immer noch keine Ping-Anzeigen, was für Fail ist.
Aber das ist definitiv keine Beta, dafür ist das Game von Schlicht und Kram zu fertig.
Äh.
Ah.
Wie kann man hier lang?
Ach, mein Dude.
Hier, 7-3, jetzt geht's ab.
Ganz geschreckt.
Alter, fuck.
Hoffentlich gibt's hier eine Perk.
Was ist eigentlich Messern jetzt?
What? Im Spawn?
Einfach Tastatur dran, ja?
Hallo, ich will rennen.
Witzig. Die Knight.
Achtung Leute, wir haben als Trick 17.
Das kann ja echt überall sein.
Ich muss auch weniger rumrushen und mehr an irgendwelchen Fenstern stehen.
Natürlich von hinten.
Trick 18 geht nicht, Trick 17 hätte geklappt.
Äh, Richtung? Welche Richtung? Äh.
Wir haben einen hoch.
Also du siehst Null, wenn hier einer gebüscht liegt, hast du mit der Auflösung keine Chance das zu sehen.
Wirklich Null.
Absolut keine Chance.
No Chance.
Achtung, Splint Wars, Splint Wars.
Wir dürfen weniger russisch.
Da ist noch einer.
Einmaler noch, oder?
Ich habe Null Plan, wo hier noch einer ist.
Wie kommt man an dieses komische Fenster da oben?
Drei Hits reichen nicht.
Da muss man wahrscheinlich Single schießen.
Das ist nicht mal ansatzweise in Full HD das Game.
Das ist keine Ahnung, 1200x700 oder sowas.
Das ist nicht mal ansatzweise in Full HD.
Das ist mit Glück 720p.
Mit Glück 720p, so wie das Pixel.
Das könnte aber auch an meinem Ollenkack PS3 liegen.
Ich habe ja keine Pro, ich habe ja die Olle.
Ich glaube eh, dass vieles, was bei mir ein bisschen an der alten PS3 liegt.
Aber ich kaufe mir auch keine neue PS3.
Das Spiel ist eh nicht auf der Controller.
Es hört sich übel an, es ist direkt um die Ecke einer.
Und wir haben viel zu viele Ecken sich zu verstecken.
Ist der jetzt gestorben?
Hier muss man Stelzen nehmen.
Kann man einfach die da nehmen jetzt?
Da war er, habe es dann gesehen.
Der stellt sich auch rein ab.
Ich kann mich geschmauten.
Ich glaube der ist down, der ist tot.
Wo ist der Dude?
Da hinten drauf, hinten drauf, hinten drauf.
Da kommt klar einer hoch.
Einfach in dem Raum campen, das ist viel zu einfach.
Viel zu einfach in diesem Raum campen.
Das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Dass man da rum campen kann und das lohnt sich.
Was ist mit der Waffe los?
Dauerfeuerabenteuer.
Das ist nicht gut.
Zum Glück überhaupt nicht verwinkelt.
Hauptsache ich mache mal Krach.
Von hinten kommt gleich was.
Ich wollte in der Schild laufen und nicht so doof am Schild hängen bleiben.
Richtig dämlich.
Aber es ist ein gutes Zeichen für mich, wenn ich mich über mich aufrege und nicht über das Game.
Das ist eigentlich niemand gutes Zeichen für alle Games.
Einmal der Typ wird jetzt geschreckt.
Gerecht rum ist sackt eigentlich über die Seite.
Die andere Seite ist viel besser.
Ich finde es mit der Minimap nicht schlecht.
Ich finde es wirklich nicht übel mit der Minimap.
Es ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich muss mal kurz umschalten auf den Rechner.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal, weil ich brauche Gameplay für die nächsten Tage.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach.
Ich nehme es jetzt einfach auf.
Einfach hier ging es los.
Ich hoffe meine Festplatte sind nicht voll.
Rekordere es jetzt einfach komplett bis zum Schluss.
Hoffentlich geht es jetzt wieder Vollbild.
Ach Moment, jetzt wo ich gerade da bin.
Jetzt ist ja die ganze Zeit immer noch verkehrt hier.
Leute, warum sagt ihr denn nichts?
Mein Sound ist doch immer noch falsch, oder?
Sound ist doch immer noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Und mit dem Mausrad geht es schneller.
Ich habe mir keine Tastatur dran.
So.
Sehr gut.
Wir sind schon wieder am Start.
Ich hoffe es wird jetzt Vollscreen.
Elgato, please.
Alter, die Software ist teilweise echt toll.
Fullscreen, please.
Fullscreen, Elgato.
Fullscreen.
Ah.
Ich werde gleich gekickt wegen Inaktivität.
War eigentlich ganz nice mit der AK.
Oh ne, das ist die MP5.
Alter, die MP5 ist so der Sack.
Mega Sack, ey.
MP5.
Mit dem Ding war es ja nix.
Freudiges Ironsight.
Ja, klar.
Fuck.
Den hat man übrigens gut gehört von hinten.
Neue.
Die Maps sind nicht klein, Zenfist, die Maps sind nicht klein.
Die Maps sind nicht klein.
Ok.
Mount.
Ich habe es zerschlagen anstatt zu mounten.
The fuck.
Cod Chaos.
Die MP5 ist wirklich kacke.
Vielleicht wird die, vielleicht wird die gut mit den passenden Attachments.
Alter, Cod, please.
Lass mich spawnen und irgendwie zwei Meter laufen.
Ok, wir müssen uns nicht rausschmelzen.
Ok, wenn die Farben spawnen, kann kein Gegner da sein.
Ok.
Ok, Knoss.
What?
Alter, voll hinten und von vorne.
Du hast erst 30 Kilometer gerade ausgelaufen.
Richtig, der Gegner da und da an beiden Seiten.
Ok, reload cancel geht nicht mehr.
Diese Call of Duty Tode, das ist ätzend.
Laufen von hinten irgendwie gebashed.
Ich muss die Kills übrigens umstellen auf UAV.
Also auf richtiges.
Alles klar.
Erkämpft was?
Oder auch nicht?
Alter.
Ok.
Ich spiele das zu umrush mäßig.
Ich meine, guck das mal an.
Letzte Runde war gut, kacke.
Man muss diesmal wirklich an der richtigen Pose einfach warten, bis clear ist.
Oder halt verkacken.
Naja, was heißt taktischer?
Rein rennen ist schonmal dumm, wie man hier sieht.
Was?
Gegner?
Ok, charge.
Alter, an jeder Ecke.
Och man, alter Elgato, fick dich jetzt mal.
Ist ja ätzend.
Was ist das für eine kacke Software, wo man kein Vollbild einstellen kann?
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
So, jetzt aber klar.
Das war übrigens kein Hit.
Ich will eine Ping-Anzeige, ohne Scheiß, das geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Ist jetzt Vollbild?
Jetzt ist Vollbild, ja.
Aber sonst läuft es flüssig, oder?
Verhältnismäßig.
Eigene Klasse, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Jetzt mittlerweile sollten wir was Gescheites haben.
Ja, immer noch nicht wirklich, oder?
Guck mal, Klei.
PC Beta ist nächste Woche Donnerstag, glaube.
Und nächste Woche Freitag, eins von beiden.
Die Maps sind super verwinkelt.
Was?
Ich war hier in deinem Auto.
Oh, wir haben was anlockt.
Erstmal 30 Dezibel Musik.
Ne, 30 Dezibel ist ganz schön wenig.
Haha, jebaited.
Was sie echt machen können, ist, dass man ein bisschen schneller wreckt.
Ich meine, das eben jetzt nicht gebracht, ne?
Aber man wreckt schon ganz schön langsam.
Achtung, Skillshare.
Ghost ist auf jeden Fall nicht über Range.
Und ich habe null Ahnung, wo wir abgehen.
Manchmal sind die superschnell down und manchmal dauert es ewig.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, jetzt werden sie gepascht.
Ha, Pock.
Wie kein Killstreak, ah doch.
Das ist nicht am PC, das ist TSP.
Ha, was willst du da machen?
Oh, da drüben war was.
Ja, mehr aushalten bitte.
Nein, fuck, Alter, beweg dich.
Das finde ich cool, dass sowas hier geht.
Das ist cool, dass sowas geht.
Ich meine, es hat jetzt zwar übelst gesackt gerade, aber das ist nice.
Wenn man so Jump-Tricks machen kann, ist wirklich...
Das ist wirklich cool, oder Eax, was sagst du?
Das ist magisch bei Games.
Pockers, perfektes Aim.
Alter, wo ist hier was?
WTF, null Durchblick, aber 10-3.
Schau mal, gute K.D., Leute, gute K.D., wissen wir in K.O.T., gute K.D. ist das Wichtigste.
Weil Penta-Nuke.
So, jetzt machen wir mal eine ordentliche eigene Klasse.
Vielleicht dürfen wir jetzt auch Killstreaks anlocken, die vorher irgendwie nicht anlockt waren.
Obwohl sie anlockt waren.
Pie Pferd.
Weapons, Killstreaks.
Kann es sein, dass man außer denen nichts anlocken darf, außer denen paar und dem hier gar nicht?
Weil denen müsste ich anlocken können, aber da ist...
Okay, Loadout.
Was haben wir noch als Field-Upgrades?
Edit Loadout, okay, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten? Weapon, Zapmaschinen, die probieren wir, MP5, nice.
Ja, sehr schön.
Loadout, nicht MP5, MP7, MP7, Pock, Pock.
Immer noch nichts gescheites freigeschalten. High Alert, Jo, Vision Pulse, braucht kein Mensch.
Diesel Equipmenting.
Eine FAMAS, ja. FAMAS gibt's, FAMAS, mit Tigerstreifen.
Okay, MP7. Jetzt kommt MP7-Stell.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Scar, so eine kleine Scar, oder?
Wie die Waffen so sind, wir haben genau drei Waffen bisher oder so gespielt.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Mini-Scar, ne?
Nein, so nicht.
Weapons hot, hot as grill.
Ha!
Man checkt nur, ob das Gegner seine eigenen Maids, die Stabs in Waffen haben.
Ha! Der geile Schneibern-Typ.
Nein, Claymore! Fuck, man! Ich war schon längst wieder zurück.
Bin längst wieder zurückgelaufen.
Habt ihr noch gesehen, Claymores haben in so einem Game nichts zu suchen.
So ein Bullshit-Item, ey. So ein sinnloses.
So ein sinnloses Kack-Item, Alter, Claymores.
Ich seh nix.
Hahaha, super.
Wenn ich einfach reloaden soll.
Alter, MonkaS.
Nochmal Personal Radar.
Weckt. Alter, von jeder Seite kommen die kleinen... Nee.
Huge weggespread.
Das war's.
Die Crews missile.
Probierst du heute noch den großen Modus aus? Man kann nichts ausprobieren.
Man kann nichts ausprobieren, das ist ja das Problem. Du kannst nur random spielen.
Ohje, was passiert denn jetzt hier?
Ich hab' wieder wahnsinns Glück.
Man kann nix auswählen, man kann bloß Quick Match spielen.
Mehr Gegner, please.
Mehr Gegner, wir brauchen unbedingt mehr Gegner auf einem Haus.
Immerall da, wo du nicht hinguckst, steht einer.
Ganz vergessen.
Achtung, jetzt Huge Play.
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht, wo es hier lang geht. Nur mal so angemeldet.
Da ist ja schon ein Dude von mir, wo kommt der jetzt her?
Dabei hab ich gerade übelste Umlaufungsstellen gemacht.
Das Ding macht überhaupt keinen Damage auf Range.
Hören die hier raus?
Die Munition leer. Dabei war das so ein nicer Flankenstells.
Das ist cool, dass man hier hoch kann.
Wo ist Tracer's hinter?
Ja, das war schlecht, gebe ich zu.
War ganz, ganz schlecht.
So, wir sind erster. Ich sag's euch doch, nach Eingewöhnungsphase wird geowned.
Ja, ist klar, von allen Seiten immer diese typischen Kotode.
Ja, natürlich sterben, sterbt mich, kein Problem.
Okay, über Range ist das Ding kacke.
Alter, diese Kotdinger, du kannst keinen Schritt tun, ohne dass du irgendwie durch irgendeinen Kacke stirbst.
Das war ja dumm, bin voll reingesprungen.
So nach dem Motto, als hätte ich mich noch ein paar Eier in die Granate reingekommen.
Typischer Kotode, wir müssen mal die typischen Kotode zählen.
Typischer Kotode 1, Typischer Kotode 2, Typischer Kotode 95.
Wieder ein Gegner von der Seite, gut, den hätten wir jetzt aber sehen können.
Versuch mal langsamer zu spielen. Ja, ich weiß, ich hab's vorher probiert.
Und das funktioniert auch besser.
Aber ich muss mp7 rushen.
Mp7 Rush, der ist real. Komm, wir haben gewonnen, easy.
Wir haben jetzt 17-20 oder so.
Max, wenn du wieder mehr Videos für YouTube machst, äh, warst du die letzten drei Wochen nicht da?
Aber mit dem Friseur, ich hab mit dem Friseur letztens ein bisschen Gears of War gespielt.
Oh, wir haben killt, Herr. Mit dem Friseur ein bisschen Gears of War gespielt.
Gears of War ist halt dumm zum zugucken, ne.
Das war eigentlich ganz, ganz lustig. Aber YouTube will da Friseur nicht machen.
Da hat er keinen Bock.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch für Loadouts?
Mp7, Mp7 find ich schon mal ganz nice.
Hier, Muzzle.
Jetzt haben wir ein Muzzle, Muzzle Guard drauf, was macht das?
Aim down side speed, das sagt es, will ich abmachen.
Hab ich das jetzt abgemacht? Ja. Optics.
In den Optics kann schon mal nichts schaden, oder macht das irgendwas Schlechtes?
Okay. Perk?
Ein Shooting in der Legs? Okay.
Das ist, weil man, ich mein, in CoD zielt man ja eh nicht.
In CoD hält man einfach irgendwie auf die Hitbox des Gegners drauf.
Ne, also der Friseur hat keinen Bock auf YouTube.
Aber vielleicht spielen wir hier noch ein bisschen zusammen.
Aber halt kein CoD. Der hat da grinded MMOs und das war's eigentlich.
Zum größten Teil. Übrigens, wisst ihr was das Beste ist, Leute? Morgen ist Freitag.
Ich hab vorhin ein 35 Minuten Video aufgenommen. Das wollte ich eigentlich heute hochladen.
Allerdings hat die Aufnahme so lang gedauert.
Also 35 Minuten, also jetzt kann ich ja nicht mehr hochladen vor der Beta.
Zwar hab ich ein Video aufgenommen zum Thema. Ich finde, da muss mal was zu gesagt werden.
Ob Karriere machen das Wichtigste im Leben ist.
Was die Leute so tun.
Das ist keine Tür.
Okay, Eröffnung. Auf der Map hab ich noch null drauf.
Wir machen jetzt unsere geilen Jump-Jump-Jump-Skills.
Alter, CoD-Tode, please. Nicht immer von der Seite.
Der Maus-Support, er ist vorhanden.
Es fühlt sich komplett anders an als auf dem PC. Komplett.
Es kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
Da hinten war einer.
Das war doof, dass ich da gleich wieder rausgestrafft bin.
Er wusste, dass ich da bin. Das sind ja mittlerweile keine Kacknubs mehr.
Die Kacknubs sind ja mittlerweile bei Fortnite. Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Er kommt oben.
Hallo?
Fuck.
Ja, ist klar.
Dreimal im Kopf oder so. Kein Problem.
Der spielt mit unserer Tastatur oder Sim oder so.
Der muss tot sein, ehrlich gesagt.
Alter.
Also man braucht auf jeden Fall saumäßig lange zu regnen.
Da muss man sich erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Ich hoffe, es gibt irgendwelche Perks, die das besser machen.
Oder diese World War 2 Perk, wo du nach dem Kill wieder geheilt bist oder so.
Weil ansonsten ist das ganz schön ätzend.
Die Spawns sind gerade... Teilweise ja, das war jetzt okay.
Ich meine, ich bin halt zielos reingecharged.
Alter, warum hübsst du auch raus?
Sollte es nicht wieder eine Stim-Injection geben?
Ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Oh Gott, ey. Das ist ja der Wahnsinne.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man überhaupt einen Stim-Shot bekommt.
Okay, wie kommt man hier eigentlich rauf?
Ah, Treppe.
Ach, jetzt ist er down.
Aber da kann man rüberspringen. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das gefällt mir.
Ja, ist klar. Aus der Hüfte mit der MP7 direkt raufgesprungen.
Nichts passiert.
Du bist ja völlig gehornt hier. Was soll ich denn das sagen?
Pre-Fired MP7 aus der Hüfte. Juckt mich das.
What? What? Ich brauche ein bisschen Tür dazu.
Chopper-Gunner. Die machen jetzt nichts.
Easy.
Aha, outplayed. Big brain.
So muss man das machen. Easy clap.
Guck mal hier, 58 MS.
58 MS, da stehe ich auf dem PC nicht mal für auf.
Wenn ich auf dem Handy morgens ins Battle-Log gucke,
um mir schon mal einen Battlefield-Server auszuholen,
um nachher zu spielen, was ich nicht mache.
Und ich sehe da 58 MS, dann mache ich das Handy aus
und gehe noch eine Runde pen.
58 MS. Findest du die Beta bis jetzt? Typische COD-Random-Wir-Verwirrung.
Oh, das ist ja wieder eine Massive-Game,
wo wir drin gelandet sind.
Wisst ihr, was mich übelst verwirrt?
Dass man jetzt nicht mehr auf der Minimap gucken kann,
ob die Schritte, die man hört, die eigenen Teammates sind.
Das verwirrt mich wirklich zutiefst.
Zum Beispiel, ich musste mich jetzt umdrehen.
Das ist übelst dämlich.
Ich musste mich jetzt umdrehen, um zu gucken,
ob die Steppes hinter mir nicht die Teammates oder Gegner waren.
Oh nee, das ist so eine kacke Map.
Doch, es gibt eine Minimap.
Der ist hinterm f*****g Felsen.
Also so eine Perk, die einen wieder heilt,
wenn man einen Gegner killt.
Das wäre was für mich.
Ich weiß, dass ich World War 2 spiele.
Es gibt sowas jetzt in der Welt.
Ja, nicht sterben, ist klar.
Hallo, hallo.
Alter, bin ich jetzt gesnackt.
Ich habe Höhe wie?
Ja, na, oh mein Gott.
Über Range ist das Ding wirklich kacke.
Und du kannst nicht reinrennen.
Du kannst nicht wirklich reinrennen.
Da bist du down.
Hab links was gehört.
Was willst du machen?
Ich habe bei dir noch nicht mal richtig geschossen.
Ich brauche Ping-Anzeigen, sonst raste ich aus in dem Game.
Was ist das für Random-Kram?
Da kommt man im Brunnen raus.
What the fuck?
Ist klar.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Kann weiter sein.
Man trifft schon, wenn man drauf schießt.
Was soll ich noch machen?
Wie oft soll ich auch auf die Dudes schießen?
Jetzt ist der Typ neben einem.
Ich will das Game leben.
Ich bin auf dem Sack.
Das Game hat gedacht.
Das kann mich jetzt am Rage-Quitten hindern.
Aber das Game hat gelitten.
Das kann mich nicht hindern.
Ich bin auf dem Sack.
Das ist ein Problem.
Ich kann einfach in ein Game auswählen.
Beides ist übelst freudig.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Krasse Layout.
Für das Ding habe ich nichts freigeschaltet.
Für die AK-47 habe ich etwas freigeschaltet.
Für die AUG müsste ich auch...
Wo ist denn die AUG?
Ist die AUG eine SMG?
Die haben wir noch nicht.
Wir haben noch einen Griff.
Für die MP7 haben wir noch einen Griff.
Macht das irgendetwas?
Wirklich?
Nehmen wir mal hier.
Was haben wir denn da?
Ich brauche keine Optik.
Macht das irgendetwas?
Das mit dem Control ist jebait.
Die Stats haben noch in keinem Cod gestimmt.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was Messer für ein Knopf ist.
Haben wir etwas Neues gekriegt?
Mein Hardline ist schon okay.
Double Time brauche ich eigentlich nicht.
Carry 2 Primary Weapons ist auch nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Was wir auf jeden Fall ändern.
Zemtex können wir nehmen.
Tactical Flash, Stun.
Stun ist hier richtig geil.
Stun dauert ewig.
Wie spielt es denn aus?
Einfach angestöpselt.
Was M13 ist in der Alpha ganz gut gewesen.
Können wir auch mal ein M13-Spiel machen.
Aber was wir ändern ist...
Skillstreak Select.
Was wir ändern, auf jeden Fall ist...
Warum kann ich den Mist eigentlich nicht ändern?
Man kann keine Killstreaks ausprobieren.
Man kann nur 4-5-10 oder 3-5-10.
Quickplay.
Maus ist easy.
Einfach anschließen.
Einfach anschließen ohne die Settings gehen.
Und von Controller auf Maus und Tastatur umstellen.
Komm wir gucken uns mal unsere Huge Stats an.
Wie auch immer.
Das geht.
Barracks.
Rank.
Identity.
Wo sehe ich meine Stats?
Keine Ahnung.
M13 war in der Alpha OP.
Na dann, probieren wir das mal aus jetzt.
Ist eigentlich die Verzögerung jetzt zu mir und zum Gameplay gut.
So hier.
Schuss, Schuss, Schuss, Schuss.
Wie es ruckelt.
Alter, wie es ruckelt.
Das sind gerade 25 bis maximal 30 FPS.
Ich brenne.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher warum, aber ich brenne.
Und man wreckt.
Man wreckt viel zu langsam.
Viel zu langsam wreckt man.
Sags euch.
Zack.
Und klar natürlich was sonst.
Mach mal Nuke easy.
Easy nächstes Game Nuke.
Aber wreckt wirklich verdammt langsam.
Gerade in dem Chaos ist das scheiße.
Also du wreckst.
Du wreckst so langsam.
Du kannst eigentlich keinen Fight nehmen so richtig, wenn du weißt, dass mehr als ein
Gegner da ist.
Ist schon ein bisschen doof.
Ja, ist klar.
Oh, den Typ hat es gerade zerrissen neben mir.
Wir stell es jetzt mal aus.
Was?
Habt ihr die Claymore gesehen?
Ein nicer Spawn.
Alter, ich halt, ich ertrag das nicht.
Was willst du denn da machen?
Du spawnst, rennst geradeaus in zwei Meter.
Du bist von zwei Seiten umzingelt von Gegnern.
Was ist das?
Ich glaube wir müssen es wieder wie vorher machen.
Wir müssen wirklich sitzen in dem Raum sitzen.
Erst mal schön auf die Ecke pre-firen.
Was willst du da machen?
Was ist das denn wieder?
Wir haben drei Kills gegen fünf.
Na gut, wir sind die Runde auch gerade erst geteunt.
Es ist mega geschwitzt.
Das blöde ist halt, die Noobs sind nicht mehr in dem Game.
Die Noobs spielen Fortnite jetzt.
Ich wusste nicht, ob der echt ist.
Game vorbei.
Meint ihr, man kann wieder Kopfsocken?
Naja, das ist echt schwer zu sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dir das nicht ausmachst.
Also für mich ist es wirklich davon abhängig, ob es einen gescheiten Serverbrowser gibt.
Oder einfach nur, dass ich einen ordentlichen Server connecten kann, den ich auswählen kann.
Und eine Ping-Anzeige.
Und vielleicht nicht in Games reingeworfen werden, wo man voll auf den Sack kriegt direkt.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe nicht einmal geneift.
Searching Match unter 0 Millisekunden Ping.
Smart. Clever.
Big Brain.
Dass er kein Game unter 0 Millisekunden gefunden hat, wundert mich jetzt.
Ja, das hoffe ich auch.
Ich meine, wo ist das Problem?
Oh, fuck. Kinder am Start.
Moment, wie komme ich in die Option?
Halt die Klappe.
Einfach mal aus dem Tastatur angeschlossen.
Oh Gott, Kinder, ich muss ausmachen.
Fuck.
Können die nicht einfach mal irre?
Oder muss ich irgendwie mein Kind was rumschreiten, nehme mich stellen, irgendwie?
Ist das so sinnvoll?
Ach Leute, wir müssen...
Hast du schon mit den Lottricks in der Lobby hinein?
Spielt er gerade?
Wir müssen, wir müssen Music, Music Volume muss weg.
Dialog Volume muss weg.
Juggernaut Music.
Einer, was Juggernaut Music ist.
Einen Juggernaut Music.
Dieses komische... geht mir auch voll auf den Keks.
Ich mache überhaupt nichts, ich stehe einfach rum.
Ich bin noch nicht aus dem Spawn raus und habe schon irgendwelche Achievement...
...Dinger.
Schreckt.
Alter, kann das mal aufhören zu shakeen?
Das nervt mir übelst.
Aber shake der ganze Bild, ja.
Und es rockt.
So, wir machen jetzt, good, good play.
Einfach, einfach campen.
Beste.
Ich kann aber nicht campen, ich halte es nicht aus in einem Game.
Ich halte es echt nicht aus, ich werde übelst nervös.
Achtung.
Ah, der denkt sich jetzt auch.
BTF, aber wo kommt der her?
Denkt er sich jetzt.
Da, fuck.
Hat er sich jetzt gedacht.
Man kriegt keine Streaks fürs Captchern, oder?
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich die ORV kriegen müssen.
What?
Ah, okay, die haben mich nicht gehört.
Okay, der Häuser rumlurken ist das beste.
Einfach Häuser rumlurken.
Fuck man.
Diese Kakottode, immer von der Seite irgendwie, den habe ich zu einem Schritt hinter mir gehört.
Nein, nein, der Friseur hat keinen Bock mehr auf solche Games.
Okay, jetzt muss ich mich umdrehen, um zu gucken, ob das ein Team-Mate ist.
Dann soll es eine Map machen, wo nur Team-Mates angezeigt werden.
Das bringt einen total raus.
Geiler Schneiber.
Ich habe hinter mir was gehört.
Oder auch nicht.
Geht es denn hier lang?
Das Sound nervt mich.
Der MP5 Sack haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Also Sound ohne Minimap von den Team-Mates.
Wer sich das gedacht hat.
Du musst dich permanent umdrehen, weil du Steps hörst und es ist ein Team-Mate.
Das ist richtig dämlich.
Richtig dämlich.
Normalerweise soll der Sound von Team-Mates sein.
Der is übelst laut.
Du hörst nur Team-Mates um dich rumtrampeln.
Guck, ich höre jetzt.
Alter, leck mich.
Ich denke, das eine hat viele gute Waffen.
Aber die ist nicht schlecht.
Das Game hängt.
Das ist nicht realistisch das Game.
Das ist genau der gleiche Kottkram.
Bloß dass ein paar Sachen geändert haben und sagen, es ist jetzt realistisch.
Was haben wir denn hier Schönes?
Ein Grip.
Das Ding ist so genau, das braucht eigentlich kein Grip.
Laser.
Hipfire.
Optik.
Also realistisch ist da nichts dran.
Mich nerven zwei Sachen echt tierisch an dem Game.
Keine Ping-Anzeige und die Schritte von Team-Mates.
Keine Ping-Anzeige ist so ein Ding, das kann man jetzt nicht direkt als Game-Breaking bezeichnen.
Es ist aber ätzend.
Aber die Team-Mate-Schritte.
Das ist wirklich schon an der Grenze.
Das ist echt an der Grenze.
Weil es kann nicht sein, dass du gerade rumschleichst und dich dann laufend rumdrehen musst und checken musst, wo der Tritt herkommt.
Und dann sagst du, achja, das ist ja ein Team-Mate.
An was ist der eigentlich gerade gestorben, der Dude?
Warte mal.
Alter, was war das?
Piss dich.
Alter.
Meinungsrecht-Klitsches.
Ja, defensiv spielen ist auch schon ein bisschen ätzend.
Es gibt immer solche Maps, wo du wirklich an jeder Ecke irgendwo drinsitzen kannst.
Aber das ist eigentlich, das kann man noch nicht, finde ich noch gar nicht so richtig sagen.
Da muss man erst mal gucken, wie sich das dann wirklich spielt, auch mit allen Kill-Zwicks und allen Sachen.
Aber die Team-Mate-Schritte, das ist echt an der Grenze zu Kanan-Game zerstören.
Das sieht ja aus wie Nuke oder Knock. Ich hab kaum Rainbow Six gespielt.
Also Schritte ist richtig Müll.
Und selbst leisere Schritte ist auch so eine Sache.
Man müsste das irgendwie erkennen können ohne Minimap, weil leisere Schritte kann auch einfach sein.
Der Gegner ist weiter weg.
Sagen wir mal, ist bei Level 10 Schluss?
Bei Level 10 Schluss? Sonst hätten wir doch schon längst schon upranken müssen.
Die Maps, also die paar, die wir gesehen haben.
Also Krasna Raid ist ziemlich groß mit zig Ecken und du weißt eigentlich nicht genau, wo was herkommt.
Also die finde ich nicht gut.
Was haben wir sonst noch gespielt? Die andere ist okay.
Die andere würde ich sagen so 5-6. Ich weiß nicht wie sie heißt.
Da ist eine Waffe fest.
Ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, was hier eine gute Eröffnung ist.
Wahrscheinlich nicht durch die Mitte.
Doch, machen wir jetzt.
Fuck, ich dachte ich kann schon mal prefine auf die Ecke, ansonsten ist durch die Mitte immer eine ziemlich dumme Idee.
Und ich habe die Musik ausgestellt und es macht immer noch Sounds.
By the way.
Achtung, wir umlaufen die jetzt.
Wow.
Was?
Was zum Teufel?
What?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Was war das denn jetzt gerade?
Ich habe irgendwie den Gegner direkt neben mir gehört.
Okay, das stirbt nicht.
Ja, mega unübersichtlich, das stimmt.
War das gerade ein Spawn neben mir? Ist der gerade erst aufgetaucht oder was war denn das?
Ist irgendjemand gecheckt?
Stälzen uns außen rum.
Hier, das ist viel zu groß. Dieses Areal hier ist übelst fail.
Außer mit der Schneiber im Graben zu hocken, ist das zu nichts gut.
Und es kann hinter jeder Ecke einer sitzen und warten, hinter jeder Ecke.
Das heißt eigentlich hast du fast schon verloren, wenn du dich bewegst.
Und es ist auch ziemlich irritierend, dass die Minimap einen ausploppt.
Was? Alter! Was? Was?
Das sind also die typischen Call of Duty Tode.
Und das frustrierend daran ist, wenn du keine Ping Anzeige hast, du kannst jetzt noch nicht mal irgendwie zusammen reihen.
Warum macht man die Minimap überhaupt weg?
Ja, weil das Spiel gefolgmäßig keine Minimap hat und nur mit einem URW die Minimap kommt.
Aber es ist super verwirrend. Du guckst auf die Map, siehst, alles gut.
Und auf einmal guckst du auf die Map, es irritiert dich voll.
Da muss ich jetzt wieder umstellen.
Okay, ich sehe die auf meiner sackigen Ural PS3 nicht.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich hab null gesehen.
Okay, nicht sterben.
Ich höre hier was, übrigens der Knopf bei mir.
Was auch immer.
Wahrscheinlich ein Teammate oder so.
Ja, Rückstoß ist okay.
Woher kommt das immer her?
Hat man einen WoF-Slider oder sowas?
Ich mein, ganz ehrlich, wie willst du das anders spielen?
Hätte ich jetzt einfach das restliche Game in diesem kacke Raum oben sitzen sollen?
Ich bin schon am Rand der Map rumgestellt, was willst du denn sonst machen?
Du hast im Prinzip keine Möglichkeit, diesen WoF zu vermeiden.
Es könnte auch von allen Seiten kommen.
Sehr merkwürdig.
Was ist das für ein Field of View? 55? 60?
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall nicht viel.
Ist das ein WoF-Slider?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Würde mich sehr wundern, wenn das ein WoF-Slider hätte.
Es sieht relativ gut aus.
Die Schritte machen mich echt fertig.
Das System mit der Minimap ist komisch.
Entweder würde ich sagen, Minimap an oder aus.
Nicht dieses hin und her gefuddelt.
Wo du dann auf die Minimap guckst und dich dann quasi im Kopf auf Minimap-Gameplay konzentrierst.
Und dann ist die Minimap auf einmal weg.
Die Map, finde ich, geht halbwegs.
Wobei da auch über 30 Milliarden Laufwege in zig Kombinationen drin sind.
Vancouver.
Jetzt habe ich 17.
Ich meine, wo zum Teufel sind die alle?
Ach, kommt erst der Chopper-Gunner an, oder was?
In so ein Game spawn ich immer gerne rein.
Ich finde es einfach nicht das COD-Gameplay ein bisschen weniger und ein bisschen mehr kontrollierbar zu machen.
Was soll denn das sonst sein außer frustrieren?
Eine Ping-Anzeige. Come on. Wirklich.
Teammates, die sich laufen wie Gegner hinter dir anhören.
Dieses komische Minimap ein-aus.
Ich persönlich fände es ja gut, wenn die Minimap gar nicht an wäre.
Das ist okay.
Da kann man sich wenigstens auf das verlassen, was man hört.
Dann müssten aber die Maps halt auch so gebaut sein, dass du ein bisschen kontrolliert spielen kannst.
Okay, das Game ist erst losgegangen.
Du hast keine Ahnung, wo was ist. Ich glaube, das Beste ist wirklich...
Ich glaube, das Beste ist wirklich, man sitzt irgendwo drin.
Ich glaube, es ist echt das Beste.
Die geilsten Games heute hatten wir, als ich irgendwo in maximal zwei Räumen von der Map gehopft habe.
Wo soll ich wissen, wo die sind?
Ich könnte jetzt einfach permanent außen rumlaufen.
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Vorhand, klar ausgelaufen, down.
Es ist ja nicht mal, dass du da Counterplay machen könntest oder so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die sind.
Wenn ich rausgehe, die können in jedem verfickten Fenster sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Jetzt komm ich nicht mit Real Life vergleichen, Alter.
Als hätte das irgendwas mit Real Life zu tun.
Real Life bist du One Hit und tot für immer.
Die Leute, natürlich habe ich Run und Gun im Kopf.
Das ist ja auch das, weswegen ich Cod spiele.
Spiele ich Armor, wenn ich nicht Run und Gun spielen kann.
What?
Okay, ich habe absolut nicht drauf geschossen, sondern gegen die Wand, weil ich dachte, er ist die Wand.
Aber ich kann noch nicht spielen, wenn ich mich aufrege.
Ich bin...
Wo ist das hier?
Jetzt, jetzt...
Guck, hinter mir war jetzt ein Teammate.
Da dachte ich, es ist ein Gegner.
Jetzt ist er down, jetzt kann es ein Gegner sein.
Gegner, Teammate.
Gegner.
Links Teammate, rechts Gegner.
Du kannst das an diesem kack Sound nicht erkennen.
Das ist so krass random.
Was willst du machen?
Du hast wirklich keine Chance.
Das einzige, was du wirklich machen kannst, du kannst sitzen.
Du kannst einfach, wenn du sitzt, ist gut.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock zu sitzen.
Ich könnte mit allem leben.
Aber mit zwei Dingern kann ich nicht leben.
Keine Ping-Anzeige und die Sounds der Teammates ohne Minimap.
Ist das ein Gegner, ist das ein Teammate, was gerade von hier gelaufen ist?
Man weiß es nicht.
Die sollen entweder eine Minimap machen, wo man nur seine Teammates drauf sieht.
Oder die sollen die Sounds der Teammates ausmachen.
Oder mein wegen den Teammates andere Sounds geben.
Irgendwie unterschiedliche Schuhe oder so.
Irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung.
Aber so ist Müll, absolut Bullshit.
So, ich renne jetzt rein in den 5 Gegner-Teil.
Ok, auch gut.
Ge-Snipern wird nicht.
Scheiß nicht angucken.
Snipern ist ok.
Das einzige, wo du ein bisschen Snipern konntest, ist auf dieser komischen, was war das?
Ein krassener Raid, da rechts außen, im Graben kannst du dich mit deinem Sniper hinnocken.
Oder in irgendein Häuschen und kannst da durchgucken.
Irgendwelche 360, Quickscope, No-Scope aus der Hüfte-Dudes habe ich glücklicherweise noch nicht gesehen.
Aber ich mein...
Wie geht es mit dem Außen-Tastatur?
Funktioniert halbwegs.
Es fühlt sich komplett anders, als auf dem PC anfühlt.
Ich bewege den Maus jetzt relativ...
Also ich bewege die Maus nicht mit diesen Ruckeln drinnen.
Ich bewege die Maus ziemlich gleichmäßig über das Mauspad.
Ihr seht ja, wie es springt.
Also es fühlt sich schon komisch an.
Es fühlt sich echt bergwürdig an mit Maus und Tastatur.
Es fühlt sich nicht richtig nach Maus und Tastatur und es fühlt sich nicht richtig nach Controller.
Es fühlt sich komisch an.
Die FPS sind schlecht, ja.
Aber das liegt an meiner Playstation.
Ich habe die allererste PS3.
Da ist die Auflösung schlechter.
Gehe ich mal von aus, mein Black Ops auch so.
Und die Performance wahrscheinlich auch.
Der Sound.
Bei jedem ist...
So, ich kann jetzt hier nicht rein.
Wenn ich reingehe, ist instant...
...Rip.
Okay.
Der Pro läuft das ganz stabil.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Woah.
Habt ihr Gas gesehen?
Ich habe Gas unten gesehen, aber nicht da.
Kopf tot.
Man kann die Tür aufbauen, ja.
Und das Schlimme ist, die Tür, die schlägt sich von allein die ganze Zeit auf und zu.
Es besteht ja noch ein bisschen die Chance, dass man einfach nur eine gewisse Eingewöhnung braucht für die ganze Sache, ja.
Kann ja sein.
Aber wo man halt definitiv...
The fuck, Alter!
Was soll ich denn machen, als er drauf schießt?
Der Sound ist okay.
Man hört die Gegner echt ganz gut.
Das Problem ist, dass du nicht hörst, ob es Freund oder Feind ist.
Das ist übelster Crap.
Und jetzt ist wieder die Minimap aus.
Jetzt musst du den Kopf komplett umswitchen von Minimap.
Ich werde jetzt von hinten gekillt.
Und die Einplanungen sind auch nervig.
Instant Rekt.
Also der Sound ist echt nicht übel.
Du hörst die Gegner richtig gut.
Es gibt eigentlich keine Probleme, außer dass du eben nicht unterscheiden kannst, wer was ist.
Ich höre jetzt links jemandem den Gegner. Ich hatte keine Ahnung.
Ist es ein Gegner, der hier angestellt gekommen ist?
Oder ist es ein Teammate?
Ohne Scheiß! Du hast keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Das ist total behindert.
Und da hinten war jetzt anscheinend ein Gegner.
Das ist jetzt ein Gegner gewesen.
Hat sich angehört. Exakt wie ein Teammate.
Und das ist jetzt ein Teammate.
Und das hier ist ein Gegner.
Und der stirbt nicht.
Es ist wir.
Du hörst um dich permanent Gegner.
In deinem Kopf.
Dabei sind es Teammates und Gegner.
Das ist huge verwirrend.
Das ist übelst verwirrend.
Das ist, ich nenne es sogar Gamebreaking verwirrend.
Das ist, du kannst das, du kannst das.
Dein Hirn macht das nicht mit.
Daddy Sounds. Also das ist wirklich krass.
Ich habe gegen die Wand geschossen, weil ich nichts gesehen habe.
Da sag ich nichts gegen, wenn die sowas überleben.
So, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo sie sind.
Okay, guck jetzt, kommen welche von hinten.
Das weißt du nicht.
Teammates oder Gegner-Sound.
Teammates und Gegner-Sound von hinten.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist wirklich, das ist mir zu dumm.
Das ist mir echt zu dumm.
Das kannst du nicht kontrolliert spielen.
Wie willst du das machen?
Teammates-Sound von hinten plus Gegner-Sound von hinten.
Du hast keine Ahnung.
Du guckst hin.
Ah, Teammate.
Bam, Gegner.
Also komplett wir.
48 FPS ist extrem, weil 48 FPS das Beste ist.
Das ist mir echt zu blöd.
Also kann ich auch nicht gescheit spielen.
Was ist das?
Das können wir bei Headquarters spielen.
Guck auf die Minimap, Alter.
Willst du mich rollen oder was?
Mal gucken.
Headquarters war diese Halo-Verschnitt.
Ja, die können die Minimap ganz weglassen.
Ist auch okay.
Dann müsste sich aber immer noch was für den Sound einfallen lassen.
Also ohne Ping und mit dem Sound spiel ich das gar nicht.
Ja, garantiert nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe irgendwas übersehen.
Und weil du auch keine richtige Frontline hast.
Aber Overlay, fuck.
Ja, ist gut.
Oben ist was drauf.
Er lebt.
Monke ist.
Oh, geschneibert.
Wenn du weißt, wo die Gegner herkommen.
Dann kannst du mich auch mal in die richtige Richtung schießen.
Wobei, wenn die anfangen zu...
Keine Chance.
Ja, du kannst nicht das nur anfangen.
Ach, guck mal, ich habe Dings hier.
Und die Predator startet so langsam.
Scheiße, die sind ja im Haus.
Fuck.
Das habe ich zu spät gecheckt.
Ich dachte, die rennen jetzt noch raus oder so.
Ah, das war Fail.
Au.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit Anzeigen.
Das kackt, verkackt.
Was?
Okay, das war recht.
Also die Predator braucht wirklich zu lang.
Okay, das war Potato Amp.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung.
Oh, fuck.
Lolwe.
Wublull, ihr müsst mehr die Emotes verwenden, Leute.
Ihr müsst mehr die Emotes verwenden, dafür haben wir sie doch.
Der hat noch, der hat noch mehr verkackt, endlich.
Kann man hier drauf?
Rüber gucken.
Ah, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das Hauptquartier ist.
Ach, es ist noch gar nicht da.
Wo ist es?
Ach, ich bin drinnen oder was?
Okay, ach, da.
Guck, von hinten.
Es hätte genauso gut ein Gegner sein können.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich weiß es nicht, bei dem Sound.
Fanto, das fühlt sich komisch an.
Das fühlt sich wirklich merkwürdig an mit Mausentastatur.
Es fühlt sich definitiv nicht an wie Mausentastatur auf dem PC.
Und es fühlt sich nicht wie Controller an.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Was sagst du zu den Schritten?
Du hast doch bestimmt auch schon eine Weile gespielt, ne?
Also ich finde es ganz merkwürdig, dass du die Team,
also wenn gerade die Minimap nicht da ist,
dass du Teammates und Gegner übelst laut hörst.
Und wenn du jetzt hier guckst und du hörst recht Schritte,
du musst immer checken ohne Minimap, ob es nicht ein Gegner ist.
Weil die Gegner können ja auch von allen Seiten kommen.
Aber dann ist es ein Teammate.
Auch ganz wir wird es, fuck, wo geht es lang?
Auch ganz wir wird es, wenn Gegner und Teammates im gleichen Gebiet sind.
Dann checkst du gar nichts mehr.
Also mir geht es gar nicht so sehr, dass die Minimap fehlt.
Wegen mir könnten sie auch die ganze Minimap wegmachen.
Das ist auch okay.
Sie müssen sich nur was mit den Schritten einfallen lassen.
Guck, ich musste jetzt hinter mich, ohne Scheiß.
Ich musste jetzt hinter mich gucken, weil ich was gehört habe.
Das hätte Freund und Feind sein können.
Und meistens ist es ein Teammate.
Ich wollte mich gar nicht umdrehen.
Ich wollte mich gar nicht umdrehen, weil ich dachte,
hinter mir ist bestimmt ein Teammate gespawnt.
Ist aber kein Teammate gespawnt.
Komisch.
Also das ist wirklich sehr merkwürdig mit den Schritten.
Vielleicht die Teamschritte leiser machen.
Eine permanente Minimap, wo alle Teammates nur drauf sind.
Ich glaube, das mit der Minimap, wo alle Teams drauf sind,
wäre eigentlich, wo nur Teammates drauf sind.
Da kannst du dir nämlich merken, wie die Map aufgebaut ist.
Weil ganz ehrlich, ich kann mir die verwickelten Maps
überhaupt nicht merken.
Einfach eine Minimap, wo du dann nur deine Teammates drin siehst.
Ich meine, es hat auch was Cooles.
Dieses Rumgejumpe, was du machen kannst, ist nice.
Du kannst von da drüben über die Container hier reinspringen.
Das ist richtig cool.
Wo war das?
Okay, jetzt muss ich hier gucken, weil ein Teammate vorbeiläuft.
Merkwürdig, echt merkwürdig.
Hallo?
Okay, also Leute, ich habe es euch gesagt.
Einfach irgendwo stehen und aus dem Fenster gucken,
funktioniert am besten.
Tatsächlich so.
Einfach mit dem Maus und Tastatur zu deiner Frage spielt sich
spielt sich irgendwie komisch.
Ich habe den Eindruck, als wäre die Abtastrate von der Maus
ein Achtel so hoch wie auf dem PC oder so.
Mach es gut, Eax.
Übrigens, falls ihr irgendwelche Hosts oder Abos oder irgendwas,
ich sehe nichts.
Ich höre nichts und ich sehe nichts, weil ich mich aufs Game
konzentriere und ich habe den Sound von meinen Follower und sowas
nicht auf dem PS, Playstation Headphone.
Also danke für alle, die gefollowert sind, alle, die mich gehostet
und irgendwas haben.
Ich weiß es zu schätzen, ich habe es bloß nicht gesehen.
Oh, 21.02.
Fuck, ich muss auf.
Leute, ich muss auf.
Monkeys, ich muss auf.
Ja, dankeschön.
Das ist dieses komische Ding, was in die Luft fliegt,
wenn man dran geht.
Guck, das finde ich richtig cool, dass man hier rüber springt.
Ich, nice.
Der geht jetzt hoch.
Ups.
Okay, auch gut, dankeschön.
Ich brauche eben seine Waffe, Alter.
Ich brauche deine Waffe, Kollege, ich brauche deine Waffe.
Ja, nice.
Hast du was Besseres?
Ja, come on, bra.
Ich habe irgendwas, irgendwas aufpoppen gehört.
Wieso ich auf muss, weil ich morgen wieder 5.45 aufstehen muss arbeiten.
Headquarters ist der, der gefällt mir bisher am besten, der Modus.
Macht einen nice Eindruck.
Konnte man sich nicht lehnen oder so in der Alpha?
Irgendwie rausgucken.
What?
Ich bin MaxFPS, ja.
Korrekt.
Facecam gibt es bei 500 plus Viewern.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Wir hatten 500 plus Viewer und da gibt es keine Facecam.
Wir hatten gestern oder vorgestern 580 Viewer.
Da gab es gibt es keine Facecam.
Guck mal, man kann jetzt das Tür zu machen.
Tür zu machen.
Dich hinlegen.
Und Predator in your face hauen.
Huge Predator.
Und das Ding braucht viel zu lang.
Nur mal so, by the way.
Braucht viel zu lang.
Machst du Armcam?
Kann Handcam machen, das ist eben ein
übertrieben nice Aim, was ich euch heute hier zeige.
Ich wollte übrigens da aufs Dach.
Dass ihr das
seht.
Ein huge Aim.
Ich wusste mich jetzt umdrehen, weil ich nicht wusste, ob Teammate
oder Gegner.
Und jetzt wieder hier.
Wie haben wir das denn verloren?
23 Kills, kann ich ja nicht beschweren.
Ehrlich, wie findest du es?
Also ich sag mal, ich sag mal zum Game an sich, noch wenig.
Muss ich ein bisschen mehr spielen.
Aber zwei Sachen gehen mir mega auf den Sack.
Keine Fingeranzeige und der Sound.
Du kannst Freude und Feinden nicht unterscheiden.
Du hast permanent Paranoia, dass der Gegner hinter dir ist.
Dann ist es ein Teammate.
Und das nächste Mal denkst du dir, ach, ich dreh mich nicht um.
Es ist ein Teammate, der hinter mir gespawnt ist.
Dann ist es ein Gegner.
Ganz merkwürdig, ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Hütterwaffensound geht in Ordnung.
Generell, es geht fast alles rein von den Mechanics her.
So wie ich bisher gesehen habe, geht das in Ordnung.
Ich hoffe, das wird halt nicht durch so Kleinigkeiten verkackt.
Weil es spielt sich dadurch halt auch so übertrieben random.
Also TDM und Domination.
Hauptquartier finde ich ganz nice.
Hauptquartier spielt sich irgendwie noch ein bisschen kontrollierbar.
Aber Sound.
Äh, die Silvana, was die macht.
Nee, nee, mit der, die kann ich spielen.
Oh, nee, nee, continue.
Das geht nicht, die ist ausgewandert nach England.
Die Silvana, die ist ausgewandert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du die hier noch Modern Warfare mit uns stellst.
Die hat sich gedacht, zahl die Kollektion bar.
Fick auf Sponsor und ist ausgewandert.
Richtig.
Habt ihr auch das Problem bei eurer Playstation, dass ihr den Ausschalter nie findet?
Weil das so ein komisches Touchfeld ist.
Äh, Flaggen, keine Killstreaks finde ich richtig schlecht.
Das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht einzunehmen.
Hat paar Kinder, keine Ahnung.
Nee, glaube nicht.
Ja, ich muss mir da mal Gedanken machen.
Und ich werde am Morgen, ich werde am Morgen meinen Senf zu ablassen in einem Video.
Das ist am Morgen mein Senf in einem Video zu ab.
Ähm, ich habe jetzt ja, wie lange habe ich aufgenommen, zweieinhalb Stunden oder so?
Habe ich aufgenommen, dass ich kann ein bisschen was zusammenschnippeln, wo ich ein paar Gegner
bashe, auch wenn wir insgesamt heute jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel gebashed haben.
Ja, ähm, ansonsten, es ist halt random, es ist kurz random, dass man, dass man, ähm,
dass man die Playlists nicht abwählen kann, das ist auch komisch.
Also ich muss alles spielen, aber das wird wahrscheinlich der fertigen Version dann
nicht so sein.
Ähm, keine Killstreaks an Flaggen ist tatsächlich ein bisschen blöd.
Was, was, was war es denn noch, was mich genervt hat?
Es war eigentlich hauptsächlich keine Ping-Anzeige und Sound.
Waffen sind teilweise auch merkwürdig.
Ja, das habe ich schon aufgeschrieben, defensiv spielen.
Das ist, das ist ultra gecampt.
Ja, und, und was halt noch dazu kommt, indirekt, da kann das Game aber nichts für.
Die Noobs sind bei Fortnite.
Die Noobs sind nicht mehr bei CoD.
Deswegen sind die Games auch sehr, sehr, äh, tryhard lastig.
Ich probiere jetzt noch mal kurz nach, die ganzen Follower, die wir heute gekriegt haben.
Also, wir haben alle am Start.
Ähm, xxcheckdiecurrywurst, xxswitchprime, dankeschön.
Killer, 47GHz, nice.
Primesub, tubix9919, Primesub.
ProfessorNonsense, Primesub.
Edzumzumzumzumizu, subscribe, tier 1.
Öhm, otsaru, Primesub.
Dexieru, Primesub.
Exet, Primesub.
NoName0815, tier 1.
Huge.
Ghostfacekiller, Prime, AskFreddy, tier 1, dankeschön.
Basilos, 1905, tier 1.
Dann haben wir, ne, das war's.
Zumindest sehe ich ihn ja für heute nicht.
Resubscribe hat der Carlson, 2 Monate in Folge.
Und der Nachtbot, auch 2 Monate in Folge.
Also hier, BigBrain für alle.
MassiveBrain.
HugeIQChat heute.
Äh, hier.
Sixhead.
Soundsettings.
Da haben noch mal, hier umstellen.
So wieder, dass ich was höre.
Das, weil sonst frage ich mich nix im Stream.
Garantiert, warum ich nix höre.
Ihr kennt mich. Vergesst sowas immer.
Ich hab wieder Winnersong.
Habt ihr mich auch Call of Duty Elite?
Moment, es gibt Call of Duty Elite noch?
Das gibt's doch nicht mal.
Haben sie noch eingestellt, oder?
Das war doch der übelste Rockrepierer.
Call of Duty Elite.
Game ist exportiert.
Wo legt der denn das Sachen hin?
Great Game. My Great Capture. Elgato Nam.
Reno.
Tja Leute.
Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns.
See you. Bis denn. Macht's gut.
Das war's für heute.
Tschüss.